the real foundation of marx's political
philosophy was the economic argument
that there would be a tendency for the
rate of profit to fall
and that tendency for the rate of profit
of fall would lead to
capitalists battening down on workers
harder paying them less than their
subsistence
uh i would revolt by workers against
this and then you would get socialism on
the other side so his
he that what he called the tendency for
the rate of profit to fall played a
critical role in his explanation for why
socialism would have to come about if
you look at marx's own vision of the
revolution it was going to happen in
england
okay the advanced economies would be
first to go through the revolution the
socialists the the primitive economies
would have to go through a capitalist
transition and this is the difference
between the mensheviks and the
bolsheviks so the mensheviks and hyman
minsky came out of the menshevik family
the mensheviks believe you had to go
through a capitalist phase russia had to
go through a capitalist period before it
becomes socialist the bolsheviks believe
they could get there in one go
the following is a conversation with
steve keane a brilliant economist that
criticizes much of modern economics and
proposes new theories and models that
integrate some ideas and ditch others
from very thinkers from karl marx to
john maynard keynes to haman minsky
in fact a lot of our conversations about
karl marx and marxian economics he has
been a scholar of karl marx's work for
many years so this was a fascinating
exploration
he has written several books i recommend
including the new economics and
manifesto and debunking economics
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's steve keane
let's start with a big question what is
economics
or maybe
what is or should be the goal of
economics well it should be understand
how human civilization comes about and
how it can be maintained
and that's not what it's been at all so
we have a discipline which has the right
name and the wrong soul
what is the soul of economics the soul
of economics
really is to explain how do we manage to
build a civilization that elevates us so
far above the energy and
consumption
and
knowledge levels
of the base environment of the earth
because if you think about and this is
actually working from
work i've learned from tim garrett who's
one of my research colleagues as an
atmospheric physicist and his idea is
that we have these we exploit these
high-grade energy sources from the sun
itself to coal nuclear et cetera et
cetera which means we can maintain a
level of human civilization well above
what we'd have if we're just still
running around with rocks and stones and
spears
so it's that elevation above the base
level of the planet which is human
civilization and if we didn't have this
energy we were exploiting if we didn't
use the environment to elevate ourselves
above what's possible in the background
then you and i wouldn't be talking into
microphones
you know yeah we might be doing drum
beats and stuff like this but we
wouldn't be having the sort of
conversation we have so it explained how
they came about that what's the
economics should be doing and it's not
so this is the greatest thing that the
earth has ever created is what you're
saying this conversation yeah we're the
most elaborate
construction on the planet and like
that's not what we've done we've
denigrated the planet itself
we don't have respect for the fact that
life itself is an incredible creation
and i i my ultimate if i had to see how
humanity is going to survive what we're
putting ourselves through then it would
we'd have to come out of it as a species
which sees its role as preserving and
respecting life
i like how you took my
silly incredible statement and made it
into a uh
a serious one about how amazing life is
life is incredible and when humans don't
respect it enough we trash it
and and that's what economics i think
has played a huge role in that so i
actually regard my discipline i would
never call it a profession let alone a
science uh my discipline
has probably helped bring about the
termination
potential the feasible termination of
human civilization strong words okay
let's return to the basics
of economics so what is
the soul and the practice of economics
what what should what should be the goal
of it because
you're speaking very poetically but
we'll also speak pragmatically
about the tools of economics the
variables of economics the metrics the
goals the models
practically speaking
what are the goals of economics well in
terms of the tools we use we should be
using the tools that engineers use
frankly and that's which sounds
ridiculously simple because you would
expect that economists are using
up-to-date techniques that are common in
other sciences where you're
dealing with similar ideas of stocks and
flows
and interactions between the environment
and a system and so on and that's
fundamentally systems engineering and
that's what we should be using as the
tools of economics now if you look at
what economists actually do
the sophisticated stuff involves
difference equations
and like difference equations you know
if you've done enough mathematics as you
have you know difference equations
are useful for like individual level
processes if you're talking about a
autonomous one it'll go from state t to
t plus one t plus two and so on but not
when you're talking at the aggregate
level there you use differential
equations to measure it all
economists have been using difference
equations so there's like a book i think
it's by sergeant and one other are
called advanced methods in economics
using python 2 volume set
it's about close to 2 000 pages and four
of those pages are on differential
equations
the rest is all difference equations so
they're using entirely the wrong
mathematics to start with for people
listening what is difference equations
versus differential okay a difference
equation is is like you can do in a
spreadsheet you'll have this is without
even 1990 this is the value for 1991 92
and 93 94. so you have you have discrete
jumps in time uh whereas the
differential equation says there's a
process moving through time
and you will have a rate of change of
the of a
variable is a function of the state of
itself and other variables and rates of
change of those variables and that is
what you use when you're doing an
aggregate model so if you're modeling
water for example or fluid dynamics you
have a set of differential equations
describing the entire body of fluid
moving through time you don't try to
model the discrete motion of each
molecule of h2o
so at the aggregate level you use
differential equations for processes
that occur through time
and that's economics it occurs through
time you should be using that particular
technology but
some economists do learn differential
equations but they don't learn stability
analysis so they simply assume
equilibrium is stable and they work in
equilibrium terms all the time and
that's uh it is the the the technical
level it's it's an incredibly
complicated
uh way of modeling the world using
entirely the wrong tools okay we'll
we'll talk about that because it's
unclear
what the right tools are yeah maybe it's
more clear to you but i've got to make
it clear to an audience well
so this is a very complicated world it's
a complex world you talk about their
uh some of the most complex
systems on earth are the human mind
the economy and the biosphere yep so
we'll we'll we'll go you know i'm we'll
go to that place i'm uh fascinated by
complex systems
i'm humbled
by them even at their simplest level of
like cellular automata
um i'm not sure what the right tools are
to understand that especially when part
uh
part of the complex system is like a
hierarchy of other complex systems yeah
you said the economy is a fascinating
complex system but it's made up of human
minds
and those are interesting those are
those are interesting perhaps impossible
to model
but we can try and we can try to figure
out how to approximate them and maybe
that's the challenge of economics okay
we'll keep returning to the basics let
us try to learn something from history
i also see as part of economics is us
trying to figure out stuff and there's a
few
smart folks that write books throughout
human history and sometimes
they name schools of economics after
them
so let us
take a stroll
through history okay
can you describe at a high level
what are
the different schools of economics
perhaps ones that are interesting to you
perhaps
ones that
the difference between which reveals
something
[Music]
useful or insightful for our
conversation okay so you know you could
neoclassical post kenzian austrian
i like the biophysical
economics and so on other heterodox
economic schools that you find
interesting okay i actually find
interesting a school which went extinct
about 250 years ago
that's where i'd like to start from and
they're called the physiocrats
and the name itself implies where their
knowledge came from because
if you go back far enough in history we
didn't we didn't do autopsies but when
you started doing autopsies they found
wires they found tubes etc etc and they
started seeing the body as a circulation
system and they applied the same sort of
logic to the economy and they became out
of an agricultural economy which was
france and they saw that the wealth came
effectively from the sun
so they saw all wealth comes from they
said the soil but what they really mean
is sun the soil absorbs the energy of
the sun one seed plants a thousand flu
seeds come back there is no surplus uh
we are simply mining what we can find
out of the natural economy that's where
we should have stayed and developed from
that forward
we then went through the classical
school of economics which comes out of
adam smith and smith
uh coming from scotland
looked at what the physiocrats said and
what the physiocrats argued was that
agriculture is the source of all wealth
and the manufacturing sector is sterile
that's literally the term they use to
describe the manufacturing what is their
own means sterile means you don't you
don't extract value you simply change
the shape of value so the the value
comes from the soil the only comes from
the soil that's the free gift of nature
that's literally the phrase they used
and we then distribute the free gifts of
nature around and we need carriages
which was the manufacturing term they
used at the time
as well as
wheat
so we to make the carriages we take
what's been
taken from the soil and we convert it to
a different form but there is no value
added in manufacturing so smith looked
at that and said well i'm from scotland
and we've got these you know
industries you know we make stuff and
it's machinery and he said no it's not
land that gives it the source of value
it's labor
yeah now that led to the classical
school of thought and that said that all
value comes from labor
uh that
value is uh is objective so it's the
amount of effort you put in that the
price two things will exchange for
reflects the relative effort that's
involved in the manufacturing so this
computer takes two hours to make and
this bottle takes two minutes to make
then there's this is worth 60 times as
much as that okay they didn't talk about
marginal cost it was absolute cost
effectively they didn't talk about
utility as a subjective thing they
ridiculed subjective utility theory
that led to marx and marx is
probably the most brilliant mind in the
history of economics the only other
competitor i'd see is schweiter possibly
keynes but in my terms of ranking of
intellectual view marx schumpeter keynes
in terms of the outstanding
capacities to think but marx then turned
that classical school which was
pro-capitalism and anti-feudal into a
critique of capitalism
which led to the neoclassical school
coming along as a defense of capitalism
but they defended it using the ideas of
the subjective theory of value so that
value does not reflect effort it's the
satisfaction
individuals get from different objects
that determines their value marginal
utility it's the marginal cost that
determines how much they sell for
capitalism equilibrates
marginal cost and marginal utility
and
the concepts of equilibrium and marginal
this and marginal that became the
neoclassical school and that's still the
dominant school now 150 years later
so that's the one that everybody learns
and when you first learn economics if
you don't have the critical background
that i managed to acquire
that's what you think is economics the
marginal utility equilibrium
oriented analysis of mainstream
economics and for example they ignore
money and people thinks economists you
must be an expert on money because
you're an economist well in fact
economists learn literally in the first
few weeks at university that money is
irrelevant
they say money illusion so they they
represent people's uh tastes using what
they call indifference curves and
they're like isoquants on a on a weather
map if you look at an isoquant it shows
you all the points of the same pressure
so you can be you can be here or you can
be in denver and the air pressure can be
the same if you're in the same weather
unit so you just draw a cell that links
together well they do the same thing
with utility and say lots of bananas and
very few coconuts can give you the same
utility as lots of coconuts and very few
bananas and you draw a basically a like
a hyperbola running down and linking the
two and they'll say well that's that's
your utility that describes your tastes
and then we have your income and there's
given your income you can buy that many
um bananas completely or that many
coconuts or a straight line combination
of the two and then if we double the
price
nominal price of coconuts and double the
normal price of bananas and double your
income what happens and the correct
answers are nothing sir you know you
stay at the same point of tangency
between what your budget is and which
particular
utility curve gives you the maximum
satisfaction
so that gets ingrained into them and
they think anybody who worries about
money suffers from money illusion
you know you you were there
uh ignorant of the deep insights of
economics if you think money actually
matters
so you have an entire theory of
economics which presumes we exchange
through data
you know like i'll i'll swap you that
microsoft surface for
actually i'll take two of those for one
of these you know we do this bartering
type arrangement in fact that only works
if money plays no creative role in the
economy
and that's where you'll find reading
schmeder
the inside that's the school of thought
that i come from that says money is
essential
money actually adds to demand and i'll
talk we'll talk about that later on so
that's the neoclassical school that ends
up being subjective theory of value
uh non-monetary
so as everything happens in barter and
focusing on equilibrium as though
everything happens in equilibrium or if
you get disturbed from equilibrium you
return back to it again
and
that mindset describes capitalism
his most interesting feature is that it
reaches equilibrium
now what planet are we on to believe
that because if you look at the real
world the real
uh
exciting world of capitalism in which we
we live
change
is by far the most obvious
characteristic of it there's no
equilibrium there's no equilibrium it's
unstable and as a mathematician it's
easy to you know you work with stability
analysis you know you work out what the
uh the jacobian is you work out your
little exponents in a complex system
you're used to the idea that equilibrium
is unstable but economists get schooled
into believing that everything
happens in equilibrium and they don't
learn stability analysis so all that
stuff is missing so onto the schools of
thought um the
treating the economy as an equilibrium
system
which was what the class neoclassical
school did is what keynes disturbed
and he really disturbed it by talking
about
fundamentally that uncertainty
determines
our decisions about the future
so when we consume you know you know if
you like visor or whatever a particular
drink you want to have you know the
current situation but to invest you must
be making guesses about the future
but you don't know the future so what do
you do you extrapolate what you
currently know
and that's he said this is a terrible
basis on which to
plan for the future
but
this is the only thing you can do when
there where there is no possibility of
solid calculation
so investment is therefore subject to
uncertainty
and therefore you will get volatility
out of out of investment you will get
fads of course booms and slumps coming
out of that because people extrapolate
forward the current conditions and
that's the normal state of a capitalist
economy and schumpeter argued that
that's what gives us this creativity as
well the fact that you can perceive a
potential demand but you don't first of
all you don't know whether that demand
is going to work secondly you don't know
who your competitor's going to be
whether somebody's going to be ahead of
you or behind if there's a fad you'll
over invest okay
um
all this stuff is the real nature of
capitalism and that's what we should be
trying to capture the dynamic
non-equilibrium monetary
violence and creativity of capitalism
that's what we should be analyzing and
the keynesian school
has gone in that orientation
they've been in my opinion inhibited by
learning their mathematics from
neoclassical economists so they don't
have enough of the technology of complex
systems there's only a really tiny
handful of people working in complex
systems analysis in post keynesian
economics but that is to me the most
interesting area so their their tools
may be lacking but they fundamentally
accept the instability of that's right
that's right and so that's what makes
them interesting so let me let me try to
summarize what you said and then you say
how stupid i am okay so then there was
the uh
physiocrats
that thought value
came from the land yep then there's adam
smith
who said
nah
value comes from human labor
uh
that was that was the classical school
and then neoclassical
is uh value comes from
like bananas and coconuts the prefer
human preference is
like human happiness how happy
how happy a banana makes you mm-hmm and
then uh the kenzian and the post-kansan
were like
yeah well you can't
you can't you can never the moment you
try to put value to a banana and a
coconut you're already working in the
past
yeah yeah
it's always going to be chaos and
stability and then you just
you're you're fishing in on certain
waters and that's we have to embrace
that and come up with tools that model
that well uh and also joseph sean peter
what school would you put him under is
he a keynesian or is he uh austrian
economics
he's an austrian austrians deny
okay that's the injury he's from austria
but
he's not an austrian economist there are
elements of the austrian school of
thought which are worthwhile what what
is austrian economics in this beautiful
whirlwind picture that you painted okay
austrian economics grew out of the new
out of the
rebellion against the classical school
so you had three intellects who mainly
led the growth of the neoclassical
school back in the 1870s as william
jevens from england uh menger who's from
austria and vol ras from france and
volras tried to work out a set of
equations to describe a multi-con a
multi-product economy where there's
numerous producers and numerous
consumers everybody's both a producer
and a consumer and you try to work out a
vector of prices that will give you
equilibrium in all markets
instantaneously and that's his
equilibrium orientation jevons is also
on about equilibrium but he worked more
at the aggregate level so there's a
supply curve in a demand curve and
that's what gabe marshall ultimately
codified
menger was pretty much saying that well
yes there might be an equilibrium but
you're going to get disturbed from it
all the time you'll be above or below
the equilibrium and what came out of the
austrian school was an acceptance of
that sort of vision that the market
should reach equilibrium
but then said well you'll get disturbed
away from the equilibrium and it's
that's what gives you
the vitality of capitalism because an
entrepreneur will see an arbitrage
advantage and try to close that gap and
that will give you innovation over time
and schumpeter went beyond that and saw
the role of money and said that
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is somebody
with a great idea and no money
yeah okay so to become a capitalist
you've got to get money and therefore
you've got to approach the finance
sector to get the money and the finance
sector creates money and also creates a
debt for the entrepreneur
and so you get this financial
engine turning up as well
and you will get movements away from
equilibrium out of that you won't
necessarily head back towards the
equilibrium so schumpeter has a rich
vision of capitalism in which money
plays an essential role
in which you will
be disturbed from equilibrium all the
time
and that is really i think a much closer
vision of actual capitalism than
anything by
even even the the industry-leading
austrians
you know hayek uh et cetera et cetera
they they and certainly ron barto i find
totally like reading a cardboard cutout
version of uh of the wealth of the
wealth of nations it's uh i find his
worth trivial um
but sean peter was rich but with the
same foundations as the austrians but
because he talked about the importance
of money that took him away from the
austrian vision which is very much based
on a hard money idea of capitalism
beta said you needed the capacity of the
financial sector to create money to
empower entrepreneurs
and that's a very important vision so
sean peter's argument is the deviation
from equilibrium that's where all the
fun happens that's where all the magic
happens that's the magic of capitalism
and like the austrians because they
focus on the deviation from equilibrium
are better than their classicals but
they still have this belief in the you
know you'll reach equilibrium ultimately
or you'll head back towards it uh
whereas they they don't they don't have
an explanation of capitalism that gives
you cycles apart from having the wrong
rate of interest
okay so there's no role for an
accumulation of debt over time so what
sean payton gave us was a
vision of the
creativity of capitalism being driven by
entrepreneurs who are funded by money
creation by the finance sector
and that's
fundamentally the world in which we live
so there's also
kids these days uh
are
all into modern monetary theory yeah
okay modern monetary theory is
accounting
i want to summarize it's bluntly it's
simply saying let's do the accounting
because what money is is a creature of
double entry bookkeeping okay what's
double-entry bookkeeping banks this was
invented back in the 1500's in italy uh
i've forgotten the particular merchant
who did it
based on some arabic ideas as well but
the thing is if you want to keep track
of your uh financial flows
then you divide
what you uh
all the financial claims on you you
divide into claims you have on somebody
else which are your assets claims
somebody else has on you which are your
liabilities and the gap between you two
the two is your equity so you record
every transaction twice on one row okay
so for example if you and i uh do a
financial transfer uh you have a bank
account i have a bank account uh your
bank account will go down mine goes up
okay and that's
the sum of the operation is zero okay
but on the other hand if i go to a bank
and borrow money then my account goes up
they put money in my deposit account the
bank's assets go up okay and they're
still the same sum applies assets minus
liabilities minus equity equals zero now
that's simply saying money is a an
accounting a creature of accounting it's
not a creature of a commodity so if you
think about how austrians think about
money and how gold bugs think about
money and bitcoin enthusiasts if there
are any left think about money uh what
they see is money as an object okay and
uh you you and i can both have more gold
if we're both willing to go to this you
know a mine somewhere and dig a few
holes and get a few specks of gold out
so there's no competition or no
interaction between you and me if money
is gold and i think money should be an
object a commodity but money
fundamentally is not a commodity it's a
it's a claim on somebody else that's
money's essence so when you do it you
must use double entry bookkeeping to do
it and then when you do you find all the
answers that come out of thinking as
money as a commodity you're wrong
so for example i've got elon on this one
so i want to get this rid of elon
because i saw him making a comment about
this a few weeks ago on twitter he said
that it's wrong for the government
effectively it seems wrong for the
government to always be in deficit
okay now when you look at it and say
well
how is money created
how does money come about when it's not
a commodity like gold would you dig up
out of the ground when it's actually
social relations between people that
create money
well money is the
fundamentally
the liabilities of the banking sector
when you if we make a transfer between
us
your deposit account goes down my
deposit account goes up
those are exchanges on the liability
side of the banking of the of the
banking sector
but if we have a transaction with a bank
uh then if the bank lends us money it's
as its loans go up its deposits go up
again that same balance so you've got to
look and say money therefore is
fundamentally the liabilities of the
banking sector so how do you create
create additional liabilities you must
have an operation which occurs both on
the liability side and the asset side of
the banking sector so if you and i make
a transaction no money is created
money
existing money is redistributed but if
you go to a bank and by taking out a
bank loan then money is created by the
bank loan so the liabilities of the
banking sector rise the assets rise
they're balanced but more liabilities
means for the banking sector means more
money
okay so that's what that's how private
banks create money and that's what i
first started working on when i became
an academic about 35 years ago
the actual dynamics of private money
creation but the government has the same
sort of story if the government runs a
deficit it spends more money
on the individuals
in the economy than it taxes them which
means
their bank accounts increase so a
government deficit creates money for the
private sector
okay so that's where money creation
occurs from the government so it's it's
it puts money in people's it puts more
money into people's bank accounts by
spending by welfare payments than it
takes out by taxation so that's creating
new money and then on the other side on
the bank
the money turns up in the reserve
accounts of the banks which are
basically the private bank's bank
accounts at the central bank
so
rather than the asset of
private money creation being loans the
asset of government money creation is
reserves
okay
right money creation money creation is a
good thing so you mentioned a bunch of
stuff like private money creation with
the liabilities and the banks and then
the how the government is doing the
reserves
blah blah blah
at the end of the day is there's a bunch
of printers that are printing money
uh what is money and then you also said
something interesting which is social
relations
between humans is what creates money
i think my mind was blown several times
over the past minute
um so it's difficult for me to
reconstruct the pieces of my mind back
together but um
basic question is money creation a good
thing or a bad thing money creation is a
good thing
because money creation is what allows
commerce to happen isn't there a
conservation of no there isn't i had
arguments with physicists over this and
it took me a long time to answer it they
thought the sum total of all money is
zero yeah okay uh it's the sum time
title of all assets and liabilities of
zero so if you imagine um
your assets minus your liabilities as
your equity
and your asset is somebody else's
liability and your liability is somebody
else's asset when we're talking about
financial assets and this is another
mind-blowing thing that i've just
recently solved myself
so the sum total of all financial assets
and liabilities is zero
okay wait i'm going to interrupt you
rudely
what are assets what are liabilities
assets are your claims on somebody else
so uh specific you mean
give me an example of an asset okay uh
do you have a mortgage for this house no
i'm renting you're renting there you go
well if you had a mortgage that would be
your your liability that would be mellow
okay the mortgage with the bank's asset
right okay if you add the two together
you get zero okay so that's zero that's
zero the money is the liability side of
the banking sector
okay okay assets are the
the the the assets on the other side can
be either created by the banking sector
which is where you get bank loans or
created by the government where you get
reserves but money is the liabilities
money is if you think about protons and
anti-protons in that sense money is like
the anti-proton it's the negative the
liability but wait
the liability
is the negative yeah how's that money i
thought money is the positive what is
the liability for the banking sector is
an asset for you and me
and an asset includes
money yeah yeah okay if you have a bank
like you've got you'd have a bank
account and you'd have some cash yeah
okay those are your assets
but the bank account is a liability of
the banking sector and the cash is the
liability of the federal reserve okay so
what what's money well money is
money money is the promise of a third
party that we both accept
to close our transaction and this is at
the bank that's the bank yeah this is
this is one of the most important works
i've ever read is a work by a wonderful
now unfortunately deceased
tiny italian economist called augusto
and he's the most wonderful personality
augusto
i met him on a few occasions
is one of the few human beings who can
speak in perfectly formed paragraphs
okay
superbly eloquent and what he did was
write a paper called the the monetary
theory of production
and you can find it uh downloaded on the
web it's uh it's pretty much open source
now uh and what he said is what
distinguishes a monetary economy from a
barter economy so i said in a
in a barter economy what we do is you
know i'll give you two of these for one
of those yeah okay barter just would
working at a relative price there are
two of us involved and there are two
commodities so with money
money is a triangular transaction okay
there is one commodity i want to buy
that can of drink off you uh two people
and the price that's worked out ends up
being in a transfer from the promises to
pay the bank that the buyer has to the
promises pay the bank that the seller
has so if i we so what you have is a
monetary transaction in a capitalist
economy involves three agents the buyer
the seller and the bank so the bank
always has to be part of it well the
bank has to be part of it what when when
i hand you the money you accept that as
uh you've now got rather than it's the
bank promising to pay me something it's
another bank promising to pay you
something and we exchange the promises
of banks and that's fundamentally money
so money
is fundamentally a threesome and
everybody gets [ __ ] okay is that a
good way to put it no it lays down for
the second like
i can use french in this conversation
that's good that's not french that's um
that's a different language i'll explain
it to you one day
you australians would never understand
okay uh if i can return to we'll jump
around if it's okay oh it's fine uh so
you mentioned karl marx
as um
one of the great intellects
economic thinkers ever yeah he's not he
might be number one you study him quite
a bit you disagree with him quite a bit
yeah but you still think
he's a powerful
powerful mind yeah a powerful mind so
first of all let's let's just explore
the human um
uh
why do you say so what's interesting in
that mind in the way he saw the world
what are the insights that you find
brilliant the marx once described his
major workers towards a critical uh
examination of everything existing
so he's a modest bastard yeah so he he
wanted to understand and criticize
everything yeah and
uh even
he he wasn't trained directly by hegel
but he was his teachers were hegelian
philosophers
and what
hegel developed was a concept called
dialectics
and dialectics is a philosophy of change
and
uh when most people
hear the word dialectics they come up
with this unpronounceable tree over
words called thesis antithesis synthesis
i can barely get the words out myself
yeah and that actually is not hegel at
all that's another german philosopher
conflict
oh fixed i thought it was kind no effect
well i'm not sure you can mix them up
all germans like you've seen me yeah
there we go
um so but if you look this beautiful
book called marks and contradiction you
want to find a great explanation for
marx's philosophy i've forgotten the
author i think it's wild w-i-l-d-a
marks in contradiction and he points out
the actual origins of marx's philosophy
i didn't know that when i first read
mark so i became exposed to marx
when i was a student at sydney
university and we'd had a strike
at the university over the teaching of
philosophy
and what happened was the philosophy
department had a lot of radical
philosophers in it and a conservative
chief philosopher
and
the the radicals wanted to have a course
on what they called feminist aspects of
philosophical sorry philosophical
aspects of feminist thought
and the staff voted in favor of it this
is back in the days when university
departments were democratic the
professor opposed it he got it blocked
at a higher level the staff
left frogged over that and then finally
the vice chancellor blocked it so that
led to a strike
over the teaching of philosophy at
sydney university which at one stage
over pretty over half the students were
on strike okay right economics began out
of that teaching of a philosophy of
feminism yes
that's good that's such a different life
to what we're living now that that's the
academic milieu in which i
developed all my ideas and and i had
become a critic i've gone from being a
believer of mainstream economics when i
was a first year student
to
disbelieving at halfway through first
year okay and i then spent a long time
trying to change it getting nowhere and
then this philosophy strike happened and
we took it on in economics and we formed
what's called the political political
economy movement and had a successful
strike we actually uh managed to
pressure the
university into establishing a
department of political economy at
sydney university as well as the
department of economics what was the
foundational ideas
were you resistant to the whole
censorship of
why aren't we having why can't you have
a philosophy of anything kind of course
well it was with much more
libertarian in the genuine sense of the
word period of time uh at the end of the
beginning of the 60s beginning of the
70s than the word libertarian has been
corrupted since then but it really was
about free thought and you went to
university to learn it was about
education i remember having a fight with
my father once where dad was angry about
the marks i was getting for some of my
courses and he said if you don't get a
decent result you won't get a a decent
job and i said i'm not here to get a job
i'm here to get an education
oh wow okay now the thing is ultimately
it's been a pretty good job for me as
well
this is in sydney by the way and sydney
in summer is absolutely gorgeous and
what does us bunch of lefties decide to
do during summer but read karl marx yeah
on the beach or uh actually inside the
uh
of the room of the philosophy department
at the university of sydney in the main
quadrangle there's sandstone all around
us and we've a bunch of about 20 or 30
of us reading our way through marx
capital like which uh there's only one
of volume one capital and
i remember walking off to that meeting
with one of my friends uh who's the law
student and we've this was a period of a
huge
construction boom in sydney so the whole
skyline which we could see from the
campus was full of what they call
kangaroo cranes which were an australian
invention that are cranes that can be
leapfrogged over each other to build a
skyscraper so here you are reading karl
marx looking at the at the mechanisms of
capitalism i looked at those mechanisms
and i knew marx argued that labor was
the only source of value yeah and he
said machinery doesn't add value so the
cranes
are worthless i'm looking at these
cranes i'm thinking i want a very good
explanation by marks as to why these
cranes don't add value
so reading through the first seven
chapters of capital what you found was
marks applying this dialectic and like
the 50 and stuff is [ __ ] that is not
how marx thought at all i was reading
trying to find the thesis antithesis
synthesis and it's not there at all in
any of marx's works and i've read
everything he's ever written
on economics from 1844 to 1894 when he
was
his last books were published there's
not one word attention of that what he
does talk about is foreground and
background intention
and his idea of a dialectic is that
there is
a unity
will exist in society and that unity can
be an individual it can be a commodity
anything at all
the unity will be understood by that
society
one particular aspect will be focused
upon so if you think about
the human being in capitalism the focus
on the human being as an object is their
capacity to work
you're a worker okay that's put in the
foreground
the fact that you're human and you want
to play a guitar and go surfing and make
love and all the other things that
humans do is pushed into the background
there's a tension between the two of
those
and that can transform that unity over
time and that's a beautiful dynamic
vision
of change so dialectics is a philosophy
of change so synthesis antithesis is uh
what does every idea have
a counter argument yeah there's a
positive and negative and you bring them
together somehow and then mark says this
foreground background foreground
is all what we think of as economics and
backgrounds all the love making we do as
humans that sort of thing and and why is
what's why is there attention well
because you you mentioned if you imagine
the unity like if you take a human
in a any preview it could go back to
cro-magnon days when we're you know
living in caves and yep
and we've got to go hunting and cook
food and stuff like that but there's no
social hierarchy as we've become used to
so you don't get labored as a worker or
a capitalist you're just a human in that
situation then you'll you've got more of
an integrated view of who you are
and i think that's one of the appeals of
a tribal a genuine tribal culture that
you get treated for the whole of who you
are you've certainly categorized you're
male you're female you're young you're
old you're a hunter you're a you're a
tool maker etc etc but you're treated as
more an integrated object when you get
put in a complex society like a
capitalist society then one side of you
is emphasized and the others are
de-emphasized so is it fair to say that
the background is like our basic
fundamental humanity
and the foreground is the machine of
capitalism effectively and when you look
at in terms of a human but what marx did
is apply this to a commodity
he said what is the essential unity in a
capitalist economy and the essential
unity is a commodity okay that's just
the essential unit the essential unity
was the unit unity an object in society
okay okay so he started from the point
of view of trying to understand what how
exchange occurs how do we set prices and
his starting vision was to say that a
commodity is a unity
in a capitalist economy
the part of the unity
that we focus upon is the its exchange
value
a capitalist produces a commodity not
because of its
qualitative characteristics but because
it be sold for a profit
so the foreground aspect of a commodity
is its exchange value
the background aspect of it it won't
succeed as a commodity unless it has a
use value
so the the background is the utility
thing yeah i see
if you made something which didn't work
okay yeah then it has you might be able
to sell it but it has no utility that
can't you can't make that into a
commodity a broken thing can't be sold
does that have the subjective yeah the
it has to have the subjective side for
people as well as the objective so the
objective is what capitalists worry
about i'll give you my favorite counter
example of that i was in i took a bunch
of australian journalists to china way
back in the period when the gang of four
was was being on trial and we did a tour
of the forbidden city in
beijing and at that stage all the
artifacts of the royal family the
emperor were actually in the building
still and we walked past one of them and
it was this
gold solid gold bar about this long
shaped like a fist turned over like this
and on this side there were rubies
emeralds diamonds you'd never seen
gemstones i mean gems that big okay and
one of the journalists asked me what i
thought it was and i said oh it's
obvious jane is the back scratcher
i walked away she caught up with me
about 20 minutes later that i asked one
of the guys it is a back scratcher wow
so here's a back scratcher for the
emperor made of solid gold with diamonds
and rubies and emeralds during the
scratching yeah and that's that's a
commodity in a feudal society
okay the cost doesn't matter
you want the most elaborate beautiful
thing because you're the emperor
so you in that in a feudal society the
commodity what's focused upon is the
utility
and the cost of production when you're
when you're the emperor is immaterial
capitalism reverses that
so the commodity in a capitalist economy
is a plastic two dollar scratcher you
can get from kmart
or target yeah and so the the use value
is
necessary but
irrelevant to forming the price now that
was a completely different vision of
exchanging capitalism to what i found in
the neoclassical theory because that
says it's the marginal utility and the
marginal cost of everything that
determines the exchange ratio and the
crazy thing about that is not so much
the
marginal utility but
the argument in the neoclassical theory
is that the price ratio the price will
when there's an exchange going on
there's two person two commodity
exchange of two commodities for between
two people
uh
they will
cha the the price will change until such
time as the ratio of the marginal
utilities is equal to the ratio of the
marginal costs
that's supposed to be the equilibrium
now mark says that's [ __ ] that's a
previous society where you exchange
stuff that you happen to have for stuff
somebody else happened to have
without any real production mechanism
being involved and he said that's like
when you when you have an eight two
ancient trial or two tribes meeting for
the very first time and one tribe can
make something the other tribe can't
make and they will therefore
the price they were willing to pay will
reflect how unique this other object is
that the this one tribe can make and the
other can't so for example the story of
manhattan being sold for 40 glass beads
it's actually 40 glass trading beads i
do believe it is a true story but the
thing is the indians couldn't make glass
beads
so they value the glass beads of the
island of manhattan okay which is a
utility-based comparison what mark said
that's the very initial contact over
time even if you don't know the
technology
over time you you start to realize how
much work goes involved to making what
they're selling you versus what you're
selling to them
and you start making stuff specifically
for sale
so you know elon's not losing personal
utility each time a model 3 goes out the
door
there's no he might get utility out of
the fact that he's created that vehicle
that concept and manufactures it and so
on but he's not losing utility each time
a model t ford goes out the door for
going back for the ancient
ancient commodity there so
the utility plays no role in setting
price in marx's model
whereas it's essential in the
neoclassical model what's the difference
between utility and marginal utility
what does the word marginal mean
and why is this such a problem it turns
marginal utility well the utility itself
has different meanings in the two
schools of thought if you take the
classical school of thought which when
marx comes from utility is effectively
objective
so the utility of a chair is that you
can sit in it
okay not how comfortable it makes you
feel
yeah okay now if you think about the
utility of the chairs we're both sitting
and they're identical from a classical
point of view we're both sitting okay
but from the neoclassical point of view
it's how comfortable it makes you feel
and that depends upon your subjective
feelings of comfort you might be far
more comfortable in the identical chair
that i'm sitting in then i am yeah and
therefore the comparison is difficult
and therefore working out a ratio
involves you've got a
decline in your each time you give away
a chair in exchange for a
iphone
you have a fall in your utility okay but
and then therefore you want a higher
return because you're losing more
utility each time the more chairs you
give away the less utility you're
getting from chairs so there's a decline
in your utility that's your your
marginal utility
so it's including your subjective
valuation in setting the price
and what mark's pointed out is this is a
caricature
of actual change in the capitalist
economy because we have in a capitalist
economy huge factories turning out huge
quantities specifically for sale they've
got no utility to the
um seller unless they're sold
okay so it's a it's a very different
vision of where how prices said and marx
used that to explain where profit comes
from but he made a mistake
and his argument was that
talking about a worker uh
as an ally or unity this foreground
background tension thing the foreground
is that you hire a worker
for their cost of production and their
cost of production is a subsistence wage
okay
the utility to the buyer
is the fact that they can work
in a factory now it might take
six hours let's say to make the means of
subsistence and that's the exchange
value and that's what the capitalist
pays as a wage to the worker but they
can work in the factory for 12 hours
that's the utility
12-6 is six
surplus of value hours and that's where
profit comes from
and that was marx's argument and i
thought it was brilliant
but it also applied to machinery
right okay let's
say no no
deep is good just want to define
uh terms don't take that statement out
of context the internet please
okay uh
you said buyer
seller
worker in a factory who's the seller
who's the buyer well you know
why is the worker
the buyer well the work is the commodity
in this case because when a when if
you're going to make stuff in a factory
you've got to hire workers
yes okay and what marx is saying the
buyer in that situation is a capitalist
so what does the buyer pay he says he
pays the exchange value that's they get
back to the commodity thing that this is
because that's the starting point is
that the essential unity in a capitalist
economy is the commodity
a commodity has two characteristics
exchange value and use value okay
exchange value of a commodity in a
capitalist economy will be its cost of
production
the use value is what you do with it
okay once you've purchased it but labor
is a commodity in this case when you're
when a worker is being hired for a job
yes so the workers
labor
has an exchange value and a used value
as well yeah youth value use value of a
worker's labor exchange value
let me think about that so if that
so the hours they put in
is the use value
interesting so what uh
what does the worker
want in this
what are the motivations are we not
considering the worker in this context
as a human being
and that's actually that's that's the
next layer you what what marks give was
just like a a layered cake
starting from a foundation of saying
straight commodity exchange and then
saying well you're treating a worker as
a commodity now a commodity is something
you know like this
okay that has so far as i'm aware no
soul okay yeah i'm not going to be
complaining if i turn it upside down
it'll fall over but it yeah
so that's there's no soul there as a
human is both a commodity and a
non-commodity yeah and therefore
there'll be a tension in the person i'm
being treated as a commodity here i'm
being paid just enough to stay alive
you know i've got a wife and kids back
at home yeah
so that that is another layer of of
thinking in marks and on that lady then
says well workers will therefore demand
more than their value so that's when you
get like political you get political and
you get money coming above that and so
on but the basic idea starts from the
commodities the fundamental unity and
capitalism
the
important commodity in marx's thinking
was the worker because that's where he
said profit came from yeah okay and then
that explains the motivation of the
capitalist and that ultimately sort of
labor theory of value and
marx's arguments about how capitalism
will come to an end okay okay
so first of all what is the labor theory
of value and actually before that yeah
what is value is that um this is like me
asking what's happiness
uh is there something interesting to say
about trying to define value you vary
and this is a huge problem in economics
there's arguments of what does value
mean
and the neoclassicals came down and said
it's subjective
its value is whatever you get out of it
it's your personal evaluation of
something your personal feelings so
they've got that very subjective idea of
value whereas the marxists and the being
inheritors of the classical school
taught in terms of objective value
so the value is the number of hours it
takes to make something
or the effort the value is value is the
effort that goes into making something
in the classical school well that's just
one
measure of objective where do you fall
where do you fall i feel
objective versus
subjective versus objective spectrum i
think you have to you have to have the
capacity to to move between one and the
other in a structured model of value
yeah well my base model is the objective
okay but above that as soon as you start
talking used it about the worker for
example um
then you get involved in the
subjectivity because a worker will be
angry
and justifiably so about being treated
as a commodity because i'm not i'm not a
commodity i'm a human being okay and
that's where marx saw political
organization coming from
so and that's subjective now and then
when you get to money itself marx
actually said well what's the problem
what's the value of money
now if you use an objective theory of
value you would say oh the cost of money
the value of money is its cost of
production what's the cost of producing
a dollar it's about two cents
so he said it can't be
the value of the money cannot be its
cost of production
or the most value i think if we remember
the phrase properly almost is value here
as it must mean the
effectively
uncertain expectations or subjective
valuation
uncertain expectation or subjective
evaluation okay but he's okay with that
he was okay with that because he could
move between different levels because he
had a structured foundation of this
dialectical vision okay if foreground
background tension
uh commodity having used value exchange
value and a gap between the two
when you're talking about
machines when you're buying stuff for
production and then
at the next level you could look at
workers worker organization and say
that's driven by being treated as a
commodity when you're a non-commodity so
the basic uh
labor theory of value
that is described to karl marx is that
value at the base layer fundamentally
comes from
the labor you put into something yeah
and
you say well there's some deep truth
there except he misses one fundamental
point which is machines can
also bring value to the world he was
saying they don't
he he was uh the only thing that matters
is human labor
not
not labor how do you measure what's the
role
of the uh whatever value machines bring
together okay
this is
this is another intriguing history
because
marx when he first started had what you
can call a uh
an exclusivist explanation for why labor
created value
and that was to say that uh there's the
labor is the only commodity
with both what he called commodity and
commodity power
so you have labor and labor power
labor is the
and i get fuzzy about this i haven't
read it for something like 30 years but
labor has both commodity and commodity
power the commodity is you can buy labor
which is the means of subsistence labor
power is the capacity to work inside a
factory
there's a difference between the two
therefore that difference will give rise
to surplus and there's no other
commodity that has this incidence of
commodity and commodity power so that
was his exclusivest argument in the
middle of the 1857
he was
visited by a guy called otto brow
in his home in chelsea
and otto returned to marx a copy of of
hegel's phenomena i think it's called
phenomenology of write i haven't read it
but that's the book and
marx was then at this stage reading
through all the classical theorists
again
and he was
suddenly he read hegel again and if you
know hunter s thompson okay okay
he called doesn't know
somebody who hasn't had enough drugs
obviously yeah but hunter is thompson he
comes to you in a dream after you take
your first
escalant or whatever and you can of
course if you know your drugs well
enough you can tell okay stoned okays on
cocaine you know well mark suddenly his
writing style in the middle of a book
called the grundrisa completely changed
he switched from weed to cocaine he
switched from ricardo to hegel okay and
what in ricardo he had this exclusivist
argument about labor and suddenly hegel
is back talking in terms of dialectics
not actually using the word but
foreground and background and tension
and then he that's where this use value
exchange value attention thing came from
is re-reading hegel 13 years after he
stopped reading philosophy because made
in 44 he was reading
just the economists so you're saying
karl marx is human after all he's human
he could be i would love to have a beer
with carl for one for carl he's carl t
he's mr marks to me
maybe carl to me i'm afraid after all
this year yeah yeah you've you've had
quite a journey together so that's where
after hegel his interpretation of the
dialects comes in the form of background
foreground and background and then on
page 267 of the penguin edition of the
grunderson
literally your memory one and a half
pages long footnote it's pretty hard to
forget because what when i when i did
this when i first read marks way way
back when i was uh how old was i 20
okay i tried to explain my explanation
of marx's use value exchange value stuff
to my colleagues in this philosophy
discussion room at sydney university
during a beautiful summer that we are
inside concrete sandstone walls
discussing marks
and i went to say look the use value
exchange value argument can be applied
to a machine what's the exchange value
of a machine it's cost of manufacturing
what's its use value its capacity to
produce goods for sale
no relation between the two there'll be
a gap a machine can be a source of
profit
now i said that and i got laughed at and
i quite literally laughed at
so when i went back to university 13
years later to do my master's degree
i chose to read through and find in marx
where he first came across this insight
so i made up my first master's thesis
failed by the way and justifiably so
okay i was learning i didn't know the
level of
academic discourse necessary i had an
advisor who didn't understand what i was
writing he got me to write for his
new keynesian audience
and it was a mess and it got failed
so i got rid of did you get failed
because like why do you think it wasn't
a good thesis it was i didn't know the
level
it was written for audience my my
supervisor thought that i should be
writing for
and it was a mess and so i met another
guy jeff jeff fishburn
uh as a lecturer at my new south wales
university and jeff was open-minded he
was not a
conventional neoclassical thinker and i
realized i'd throw out the half that
bill had got me to do
focused just on marx and so i decided to
read mark's in chronological sequence
from his very first works of economics
which are called the economic and
philosophical manuscripts of 1844
and he wrote those in a garrett in paris
after he'd been expelled from prussia
and so he decided to read uh the
having been an expert on philosophy and
regarded as the
towering intellect of of hegelian
philosophy and in prussia but driven out
because he was a radical he he ended up
writing a uh running a newspaper or
being writing for a newspaper and he was
reporting about the eviction of peasants
from the forests taking away their
feudal rights and so this is where his
passion
for
economics and humanity came from and he
was a poet
as well i mean he wrote love parity to
jenny von west west hale and that's his
first published works were pretty much
in poetry
he was a rouse about he was you know
a wild character we'd probably fight
like crazy i imagine if we met uh
over the beers
i'm slightly even though i can be
i can get involved in an argument like
nobody's business no really no really
but i'm a bit more peaceful of
personality oh you think marx is
feistier than you he was fasty but uh
fasty with he could be arrogant like i'm
uh i've got an intellectual arrogance
i've yeah come to accept that but
there's like a fundamental humility to
you yeah if you're saying marx is like
he's ego that's the case
yeah i'm guessing
i'm never going to meet him well the
beard says ego to me the beat is huge
yeah that's that's that's huge okay so
this is interesting you went
chronologically right through his word
the development of the human being
through his works yeah and i was trying
to find the point at which he discovered
this use value exchange value idea and
it occurs in a footnote on page 267 to
268 of the penguin edition of the
gundriessa which his notes he was taking
literally not meant for publication
literally sitting at a stall inside the
british museum i think reading all the
classical authors in chronological
sequence and then somebody throws hegel
at him and suddenly he's talking in
hegelian terms and he suddenly says is
not
because it's whole value issues what is
values is exchange value use value how
do they relate to each other that's what
he was thinking about he said is not ex
use value which was left out of the
classical school a fundamental aspect of
the commodity
is there not a tension between the use
value and exchange value
just so we're clear in that context use
value is kind of the subjective thing
exchange value is the objective yeah and
marx was found a way to integrate the
two
but he was focused on
labor being the only thing that can
generate both the user's value and the
exchange value but no
if you look at the classical school
they focus on exchange value objective
look at the neo-classical they focus
upon use values subjective or they call
it utility
so marx coming from the ricardian
tradition
basically dismiss the role of utility
and then when he reads hegel he's
suddenly starting to think in terms of
unities and exchange value and use value
is the unity of the commodity
and he thinks well i can't ignore use
value
so rather than leaving it out completely
which is what ricardo and smith does
i've got to somehow bring it in and this
hegelian insight occurs to him and you
it's remarkable to you i really
recommend taking a look at the book even
just to look at that particular page
because what it would have been is it's
shown as a footnote but it would have
been him saying oh wow when his asterisk
asterisk is not uh
use value a fundamental aspect of the
unity of a commodity so in the notes you
see the discovery of an idea in the
human being and it's beautiful the
integration of an idea and he actually
writes does this have significance in
economics question mark and then he
probably went home that night
and like that that that idea changed
yeah it changed him completely okay and
from that point on his writing was
completely different but he still had
this idea from the ricardian days of
saying that labor is the only source of
value using an exclusive argument to say
there's something unique about labor
that explains why it's a source of value
but suddenly this insight occurs to him
and he thinks i can get a positive
derivation
i can use use value and exchange value
and the fact they're not related to each
other has a dialectical tension to
explain surplus value and that's what he
does so he goes from a negative
explanation of where value comes from to
a positive explanation on that page of
the grindr he then triumphantly
uses it to explain why labor is a source
of value you buy it for its exchange
value you use its use value they're
unrelated the use value will be bigger
that's where profit comes from
then he does exactly the same thing for
machinery about 30 pages on
he says uh it also has to be
contemplated
which was not done before this is wrote
nice to himself by the way that's it's
written in really in a colloquial style
that the use value of a machine
significantly greater than its exchange
value he actually left out the word is
it's useful this is obviously to be
determined it'll be a translation into
english of the german i'm sure i don't
know i haven't i haven't seen the
original notes i'd love to see them but
uh he says he lives out the word is
it also has to be contemplated that the
exchange the use value significantly
greater than its exchange value i.e that
the contribution of the machine to
production exceeds its depreciation
and that
was an insight which undermined
his explanation
for revolution
okay can you say that again the uh the
cost of production exceeds is
depreciation is that
okay can you linger on that i um well
what mark's argued and you read this in
capital and i read this in capital when
i first saw
the contradiction in his own thought
he said that no matter how useful the
machine is
uh whether it has uh took a hundred
hours to make or cost 150 pounds it
cannot under any circumstances add more
to production than 150 pounds
which
in his old exclusivist logic he could
justify
and which in his modern is his post 1857
argument is [ __ ]
can you steal man his case can we go to
the mind marks and thinking if a machine
costs
a hundred bucks
he can't be ever more
bring more value than a hundred bucks
but that contradicts his previous logic
because what do you see what he said is
uh
you'd have a commodity is the essential
unity in capitalism
capitalism focuses upon the exchange
value that pushes the use value into the
background and there's a tension between
the two
what that means is the exchange value of
the commodity sets its price the use
value is independent he called them
incommensurable he literally would use
the word
incommensurability between exchange
value and a use value whereas
neoclassicals make them commensurable so
saying exchange value and use value in
incommensurable
and that normally means that exchange
value is objective like the number of
hours it takes to make something useful
is subjective how comfortable the chair
is the fact you can sit in a chair
so that's incommensurability but when
you apply it in production
the exchange value of something is
objective it's how many hours it takes
to make a machine or how many hours it
takes to make the means of subsistence
for a worker the use value is also
objective you're making commodities for
sale
and the worker does six hours six hours
of work will make them the
means of subsistence for the worker but
the worker will work a 12-hour day
and the six hours becomes a gap
now that's incommensurability between
use value and exchange value of labor
but when you look at what he said about
no matter how long how it takes to make
a machine or how many pounds it costs
he's saying they're identical
and that's contradicting his own logic
well what's what's the youth value of a
machine fact that it can produce
goods for sale exactly the same as the
worker
now what i've in my modern
reinterpretation of marx which brings in
my work on energy
i see both labor and machinery as a
means to harness energy
and produce useful work
and they can both do that in fact they
do it together it's a collective
enterprise
okay so
and we'll go to that so there's no
there's no fundamental difference from
exchange value and use value perspective
between a human and a machine and
therefore they're using the same logic
they can both be a source of surplus
yeah which is what marx contradicted
because
his explanation for where socialism
would come from is that only profit
comes from late profit comes only from
labor
over time will add more machinery than
labor that will mean a falling rate of
profit and therefore a tendency towards
socialism and what he did in that
insight in 1857 is contradict
his own idea about what would lead to
socialism
and he couldn't cope with it okay what's
the difference between
marxian economics
and marxist
political ideology
the gap between the two the overlap the
differences what the the real the real
foundation of marxist political
philosophy was the economic argument
that there would be a tendency for the
rate of profit to fall
and that tendency
for the rate of profit of fall would
lead to
capitalists battening down on workers
harder paying them less than their
subsistence
uh i'll revolt by workers against this
and then you would get socialism on the
other side so his
he that what he called the tendency for
the rate of profit to fall played a
critical role in his explanation for why
socialism would have to come about he
was saying it would have to come about
or is it a good thing for it to come
about um
he had assured but he was trying to say
it must
so you if you look at marx in the
history of radical thought he was
preceded by what were called utopian
socialists
sansamon even the cadburys company came
out of utopian socialist and they had an
idea about a perfect society in the
future where people were properly
rewarded were treated as human beings
rather than cogs in a machine and all
this sort of stuff and they said
socialism should come about because it's
it treats humans better than capitalism
does
marx said i can prove that socialism
must come about
so he preferred he had a utopian vision
of a future society but he thought he
could prove that it had to come about
and the the proof
relied critically upon
tendency for the rate of profit to fall
and that relied upon labor being the
only source of profit
what what was his utopian view so this
this idea from each according to his
ability to each according to his needs
yeah is that
the
utopian i think it's utopian in in the
context of our modern world
it it it says that you
you rather than being rewarded like jeff
bezos gets enormous fortune uh you get
what you need
not what you want
necessarily all what all needs is
fulfilling it was it was a vision of
utopia we could be a fisherman in the
morning um a poet in the afternoon and a
chef at night okay that's paraphrasing
one of his phrases so he did have a
utopian vision of a future society and
he did think human creativity would be
much much greater under socialism than
it was under capitalism he was wrong
uh so let's explore in different ways
where he was wrong you're saying there's
a fundamental flaw in the logic
but also if we can link
if we can explore
the high-level philosophical concepts of
socialism too like the dreams of a
utopia yeah so what um first of all what
is socialism
that's another loaded term
socialism particularly in america is a
very loaded term and what americans call
socialist is um a large amount of
provision of services by the state which
is commonplace in europe it's still
moderately commonplace in my own home
country of australia
and
and that americans
will call you know public education
socialist it's a total parody of the
word
uh
strictly speaking what socialism meant
is the public ownership of the means of
production no private ownership for the
means of production what is the means of
production machine factories factories
so all the goods that are produced in
factories no the means
of producing the goods owned by a
centralized entity yeah
centrally planned this is what it was
actually was done under god's plan under
the soviets uh and even with a
collective collective farms as well you
know no longer owns your land the state
owns your own the land you worked on the
land and this was supposed to be a
utopia
right now does that turn out to be one
and we'll talk about maybe your ideas of
why didn't turn out to be one uh so the
the fascists did the same so it's just
fascism also
fascism
so called national socialism it's also a
kind of social so yeah but there was no
it wasn't pub public owners there was
public direction so the state would tell
factories what to do with a still
private profit and a large part of why
the nazis succeeded was the extent to
which they managed to co-opt major
manufacturers in germany
uh so
it's you know it's direction versus
ownership it's a dictatorial i mean
that's a very particular implementation
yeah so you have to you have to consider
the full details of the implementation
but it's basically
dictator guided yeah
if you want to if you want to take this
if you want to take a a proper vision
then you have to say it's the ownership
of the means of production by the state
yeah okay versus the ownership by
private that rules out the nazi period
do you use the word that again they're
bastardizing as much as americans do in
the opposite direction
well what does ownership exactly mean
well it's
it it became incredibly complicated and
this is um the and this is actually the
best work on this is done by a recently
deceased hungarian economist called
janos cornei
and corney tried to explain why
socialism failed
okay because why did socialism fail in
your view in his view in giannis is you
and your viewers yeah i think janus is
100 correct and it's it's a brilliant
piece of work so i'm going to be really
paraphrasing his view and he imagined a
ideal socialist society and there wasn't
a stalin there weren't purgers and you
lived up to all the ideals that marx had
for socialism so he said in but you do
it in the context of a economy which is
incredibly primitive russia okay because
if you look at marx's own vision of the
revolution it was going to happen in
england
okay the advanced economies would be
first to go through the revolution the
socialist the the primitive economies
would have to go through a capitalist
transition and this is the difference
between the mensheviks and the
bolsheviks so the mensheviks and hyman
minsky came out of the menshevik family
the mensheviks believed you had to go
through a capitalist phase russia had to
go through a capitalist period before it
become socialist the bolsheviks believe
they could get there in one go
okay
bypass the capitalist phase do the
development under uh
socialism rather than under capitalism
and this is what jana janus was actually
analyzing you start from a primitive
you know
feudal economy
very little industrialization and you
want to
jump to a
in advanced industrial society
from that foundation
so he said what you
have then for is a whole range of
industries all of which need as much
resources as you can get for them okay
so you want to develop agriculture
mining
industry every little division of it
they all have legitimate demands on the
resources of the country and the state
that means that all your resources are
fully employed and are probably over
employed
so you have a resource constraint
in that society
the easiest way to cope with a resource
constraint is to produce last year's
commodity not to innovate not to make
change so what they will give you is as
you start to
add you know you invest so you now have
a beginnings of a steel industry
beginnings of a car industry and so on
you start investing but you continue
producing the same product you made last
year
and i have a perfect personal example of
that which i'll throw in now if you like
any pretty heavy conversation i know my
first major girlfriend uh had a
brother
who
wanted to get a motorbike but he
couldn't afford a
honda or a kawasaki at the time they
cost about three thousand dollars for a
650cc japanese motorbike he found he
could buy a cossack
six hundred and fifty dollars one dollar
per cc
so i was there when i got breathtaking
this this is in her this is in
suburban sylvania waters
in sydney so this
crate arrives with the cossack motorbike
inside it so we take it apart it's then
got all these wooden pailings we have to
pull off the wheeling padlings to open
it up then there's oil safe rag over
this thing which is tied on a on a
wooden base yeah we take the oil soak
rag off and we stare in all its glory in
a 1942 bmw yeah okay it was exactly the
same as steve mcqueen and the great
escape
so the russians for 30 years were making
the same bloody motorbike it had a
bicycle seat yeah okay and this is what
that's how they cope they've just made
the same damn machine every year they
said so that's that's the outcome
you actually want the best possible
world you're trying to build as fast as
possible you're paying workers as high
wages as you possibly can and that leads
to a world where you don't innovate
you said capitalism on the other hand
pure capitalist economy you're trying to
pay workers as little as possible
you have competitive industries you're
trying to take demand away from your
rivals you have kawasaki versus honda
versus
you know
bmw etc etc the way you get demand away
from your competitors is by innovating
so what you will get is cycles and booms
and slumps but you'll innovate and
change over time
so what you found was this huge gap
between socialist volume production with
no innovation and capitalism with
innovation
so that was the fundamental failing that
janos corner saw saw why did why does
socialism not innovate
because if you go back to
his famous historical incident where
khrushchev in the united nations
bangs takes off his shoe and bangs the
death says we will bury you he literally
we're going to bury you in commodities
yeah we're going to produce more output
than you are and he was wrong
because fundamentally in the long term
to bury somebody
in commodity production you have to
innovate
yeah and like there's also there's
another
remarkable soviet engineer who was given
the job of interpreting marx's ideas of
industrial sectors so he had the
commodity sphere the industry sphere
sector one sector two sector three uh
sector one producing consumer goods
sector two producing capital goods
sector three producing luxury goods for
capitalists and so he had a three sector
model of the economy and he was talking
about the dynamics between them and
what feldman did was reinterpret this as
an engineer would reinterpret it which
was brilliant work
so what he said was
you you need to produce the means of
production
if you want to grow quickly you focus on
producing the means of production rather
than commodities so you don't make cars
you make car factories
okay you make a few cars but most of the
other goes into expanding how many
factories you have and what he did was
do a mathematical model where you'd
start off with very low levels of
consumer good output but then you would
just go exponential
okay now i took a look at that back when
i was doing my master's degree and the
training in mathematics i took
feldman's equations and then looked at
what was actually driving it was he was
imagining correctly a huge pool of
unemployed labor
if you go back to the earliest stages of
soviet industrialization back in 1917
post the second world post the first
world war
you had all these unemployed workers you
had all these peasants you could take
off the land and put into factories so
you had a huge supply of workers
what you had to do was build the
factories so you're building the
factories but at a certain point you
exhaust the supply
of
un lowly employed or unemployed labor
and so rather than having this this
exponential takeoff you hit a ceiling
and then you can only grow as fast as
the population because you're not
innovating
okay so that's what actually hit the
sofa soviet system
and it's why they never buried the
western consumer goods and instead why
eastern consumers looked in envy of the
goods being purchased by their western
people they said if that's exploitation
we want exploitation
so okay there's a lot of interesting
stuff to ask here which is
so marx's vision
for the
socialist
utopia is you have to go through
capitalism
the mensheviks were true to marx's
original idea right so is there
a case to be made that in the long arc
of human history on like human
civilization on earth
that we're going to live out
marx's vision for utopia which is
like will we run into a wall with
capitalism i think we are running into a
war with capitalism in fact i think
we've already gone through the wall and
we haven't yet realized we've smashed
our skulls
okay
but on the other side um we're bleeding
and everything like that uh is
does marx have any insights on what the
other side of capital and what is it i
think that beautiful phrase of ramich
according to his ability to each
according to his needs
describes what we sh we should end up
with
and i think that's actually if i think
about you know you know i'm an elon musk
fan
that's what i think is partially going
to be the nature of society
if we build one that functions on mars
because and i've actually seen the
interview with his the italian who's
involved in designing what the future
colony will look like he was actually
asked this question can there be
enormous inequality in martian
civilization the guy said absolutely not
because the resources we get in resource
constraint applies uh you simply can't
give somebody
a underground bunker 100 times the size
of somebody else's 100
underground bunker
there's a the the scarcity of resources
imp imposes a need for uh for for
equality overall is that always that's
interesting i mean the scarcity or
resource
wait but i feel like that's the
contradiction i thought
when you're thinking you know classical
about scarcity yeah i'm i'm barely
thinking at all
uh
uh so wait i
i thought scarcity the best way to build
on top of scarcity is a capitalist type
of machine no this is this is where
again our vision of what scarcity is is
wrong
because
and ricardo said this best actually
better than marx because ricardo said
there are some products
uh whose value is determined entirely by
their scarcity yeah
paintings
rare wines
et
etc
i said they are things you cannot
reproduce in a factory so the essence of
capitalism is what you can make in a
factory
and therefore for these unique objects
these rare objects and the picasso
painting
uh you know a beautiful bottle of wine
etc etc then the utility it can't be
reproduced easily so its price will be
determined by subjective valuation you
said what we're talking about in
capitalism is the stuff you can make on
mass okay and that that that is the true
focus of the capitalist economy and that
is not about scarcity that is about you
the only scarcity applies when you don't
have the resources to make them anymore
or you can't use the energy involved
because you'll damage the biosphere with
too much which we've already done okay
but fundamentally the scarcity that
neoclassicals have made us think about
and austrians think about as well
is non-reproducible but the essence of
capitalism is the commodity the back
scratcher the two buck back scratcher
anybody can you know the cheapest chips
to make and that's why you can make a
profit out of them um not not the
elaborate gold thing with diamonds and
rubies that only the king gets so we
think
our vision of scarcity has been
perverted by neoclassicals analyzing the
exception to capitalism and calling it
capitalism
okay fair enough so you know let's put
mars aside because i think there's a lot
of
strange factors that have to do with a
whole other
planet
civilization
that we don't quite understand like how
economics works
with um
with different geographic locations one
of which have
new challenges
which is what essentially this is i
don't i don't know if you can apply the
same economy i'm saying
your question i think
will will be forced into that ultimately
by having to make a compromise with the
ecology
and we've been ruthless about the
ecology of this planet and we're going
to pay the price for it
so
if you have a
planet where you can't be ruthless
okay well yeah okay you have to mine it
as carefully as possible
then
those that that utopian might be imposed
upon you for the needs for survival on
that planet back here
uh
marx's util utopia was still the one
that ignored the ecology
and i think
uh if i have a vision of a utopia in
future it's got bugger all to do about
what humans get out of it
it's what humans respect
they have to respect life
so i don't see that as i see that as a
as a one-eyed utopia a utopia for a
single species as if it can exist on its
own which we should know it can't uh
quick bathroom break yeah
that would be great
we took a little bit of a break and now
we're back we needed to take a break
because my brain broke and i'm
piecing it back together you mentioned
ecology and life and the value of all of
that
we'll return to it if we can
but
first
we said
why this kind of
this idea of why socialism failed can we
linger on this a little bit longer
and how did the ideas of karl marx lead
to stalinism so this particular
implementation yeah
um
is there something fundamental to these
ideas
that leads to a dictator and that leads
to atrocities
there's something about the mechanism
the bureaucracy that's built that leads
to
a human being that's able to
attain
integrate
uh absolute power and then start abusing
that power all that kind of stuff like
some of the history of the 20th century
is that
inextricably connected to the ideas of
karl marx i think to some extent it is
but i'm going to also say that if it
hadn't been for the bolsheviks
interpreting marx and saying we can
reach socialism without going through
capitalism
then
it might not have happened
so if you look at the like the
mensheviks were a rival
political group in russia
and that's where heiman minsky who's a
huge inspiration for me so he's an
economist who was maybe can we take a
little attention who was hyman minsky
yeah harmon minsky uh was the person who
developed
a analysis of capitalism based on
financial instability
and he was actually the
phd student of joseph schumpeter
and
an austrian economist as well whose name
i've forgotten temporarily um
and he
asked him his parents were
both refugees from russia
during the stalinist period
because the mensheviks were being wiped
out in russia just like any other
opponents to
the bolsheviks were being eliminated so
i think his parents met in chicago
still remain socialist still remain
politically active and
he was educated in a family that was
just
imbued with marx as his vision
he and ended up fighting in the second
world war
on the american side
coming back to america and studying
mathematics
and then also doing an economics degree
leading to a phd
and the question he posed for himself is
what causes great depressions
and he put it beautifully he said can it
happen again it being the great
depression and if it can't happen then
what has changed between the society
before the first second world war and
after that makes a depression impossible
what's the answer to those two questions
can it have his answer was yes it can
happen again
but what has prevented happening by the
time he started writing about it which
was the
um late 50s to the
mid 80s late 80s we met once but only
once or a beer
over a beer no he gave a seminar at new
south uni
any bit of an obstructionist bastard was
wow
it means argumentative and and likely to
dismiss you so like a good mate of mine
was the guy i brought him out to
australia got a guy called graham white
we're still g'day graeme we're still
good mates g'day graham
i love your language and you're actually
it's a great actually there's a it's a
really good tick tock i saw earlier
today with an aboriginal guy saying he
loves the australian language because
it's absolutely ironic and as you're
asking australian a question and he'll
give you an answer which is the opposite
of what he means and you've got to work
out the rest of yourself yeah this it
goes out to another aboriginal
maintenances uh g'day mate says how are
you doing oh not bad
what have you been doing recently well
not much
uh
when are we going it's not not not too
far not too soon yeah whereas they're
not too far away and all negatives and
he's a beautiful beautiful rendition
yeah yeah that's the cool thing about
the internet culture
they appreciate that ironic side like
for example the best compliment you can
give as an aboriginal to somebody else's
that's deadly
that's deadly that's a compliment that's
deadly okay yeah i wanted another mate
of mine just comes the australian
language if i call you a bastard that's
a compliment yeah depending on how i
intonate the word bastard
bastard
bastard that's deadly yeah i love that
and there's something unfortunately
there's something about the british
accent that makes people sound
maybe brilliant maybe sophisticated uh
yeah
now that's unfortunately the downside of
that yes you can sound pompous
there's something about the australian
accent that you just can't sound
brilliant
it humbles you you sound like you're
having a lot of fun there's wit there's
all that stuff yeah but you just can't
be like carl you know karl marx an
australian accent would just not come
off that is a very good point you would
not be able to pull off the beer yeah i
mean i just yeah it's fascinating that
the accent determines
you know
something about the person maybe it's
the chicken and the egg too it drives it
drives the way of the discourse
obviously there's a lot of brilliance
there's a lot of brilliance in your work
yeah but it sounds like you're always
having fun yeah and like this
poncho's got a lot of australian mates
here yeah he spent uh what about about
how long in australia
year and a half and he's got all these
mates who replace aussie rules football
in austin you should join them one day
oh well it's actually rough it's a very
creative sport it's much more fun it's
different than rugby oh very rugby is a
little hopeless rugby has two two morons
smashing their bodies against you know
easy now sorry sorry we did not mean to
offend the rugby fans in the audience
well okay what's so it's too simplistic
it's too simplistic it's it's i mean
there's skill in it i've seen some
really skillful rugby union and rugby
league players in my day yeah but it
fundamentally if you hit somebody hard
enough they go down yeah okay whereas in
the aussie rules it's about catching the
ball and then kicking the ball and skill
more skill and it's it's a and the
bodies of the athletes uh i can actually
get off me measure what a sport is like
by the bodies it creates and you get
these incredibly elegant
uh life muscular forms out of aussie
rules such beautiful words you have in
your vocabulary life i don't even know
but i'll i'll
i'll assume you know what it means and
maybe somebody in the audience okay so
all right fine
we should also mention that you've in
your youth
uh you know like like last year have had
uh olympic weightlifting yeah
that's part of your life so you're a
long time ago and like you said tennis i
also played tennis for many many many
many years okay yeah it's a it's a
fascinating game it's a wonderful game
yeah that's my favorite game
karl marx and stalin
yeah so how how do we get onto aussie
football australian and the accent i'm
not really sure you talked about um the
way i said something about karl marx and
wood karl marx anyway we got there yeah
we got there but now we return but back
to marx i think it's not the destination
i think mark's
the failure of of socialism with diana's
corner captured beautifully this idea of
what he called demand constrained versus
resource-constrained economies
and
capitalism is demand constrained okay
and and this is again where neoclassical
theory is completely wrong empirically
completely wrong so the neoclassicals
have a vision of capitalism being
resource constrained and it's about
maximizing your usage of resources
subject to constraints and as corn i
said that's really what happened unto
socialism what happens under capitalism
is that you have
15 20 companies producing automobiles
they are all trying to capture as much
of the market as they can if you add up
their marketing plans you're going to
get 120 130 percent of the actual market
so they're all going to have excess
capacity when you build a factory you're
building it with a plan for it to exist
for 5 10 15 years you have to have
excess capacity in the factory so that
means that capitalism has a far greater
productive capacity than it actually
uses and then the way that you manage to
get demands into your factory is to
innovate and produce something nobody
else does or you're producing in volume
and when somebody produces like a bung
tire comes out of firestone then
goodyear is ready to expand its
production and take advantage of that so
that's that's the actual nature of
competition in capitalism and that means
that we get a cornucopia as of goods
even if we're lowly workers the variety
of goods and capitalism is overwhelming
and and that's just doesn't happen in
socialism you get your 1942 cost stack
as your motorbike that's it when you put
your money down to buy a refrigerator
it'll arrive in 10 years
because the factory's already fully
constrained
so all these resource constraints mean
that people aren't happy
under socialism
and if you've got a whole bunch of
people
that aren't happy
then the best way to control them is to
suppress them
so i think in that sense ultimately yes
it does lead to something like stalinism
so it's easier to give happy people
freedom
yeah i mean happy people get pretty
silly outside i'm not particularly the
extent to which americans overused and
distort the word freedom drives me by me
um well but you know
all of these words can be distorted but
they all at the core have some
fundamental power and beauty and then we
just distort on the surface for the fun
of it yeah just start battles on twitter
and so on but what citizens of the
soviet world didn't feel was freedom
yeah not just in first of all it wasn't
freedom to buy commodities the
commodities are supposed to be on the
shops weren't there
uh the volume couldn't be produced and
what you then got out of that as well
was the you know the classic soviet joke
they pretend to pay us and we pretend to
work
okay
so you're not motivated oh the guy i
went to cuba about oh eight years ago
yep invited to give a talk then and i'm
staying in a hotel itself the hotel's a
story
there's one day my meetings were
cancelled so i thought i might go down
to the beach and they had in the hotel
they had a wing which is the tourist
office and there were three women
working inside the office so i thought
i'd just go up and ask them you know how
do i get to the beach and one of them
says to me i stood there just stood in
the
in the room
waiting to see if they'd make eye
contact with me
three women nobody else in the place
none of them looked at me so i finally
went up to one of them and said i want
to go to the beach and do some surfing
where she said i can get a taxi outside
now fundamentally she was saying i'm
being paid [ __ ] money here
i'm not gonna i don't want to work
i'm not going to do
anything
apart from sit here and qualify for my
time
and as much as there are reasons the
cubans have suffered from american
embargoes and all that sort of stuff
you've still got that fundamental
shortage economy
that uh the corn i spoke about coming
out of the structure
of central ownership and central control
of distribution and investment based my
heart because i think some of the
effects of that persist throughout time
it become part of the culture too yeah
yeah it's very negative culture yeah
yeah well from
from the western perspective well even
from the people living through it i mean
like i had enough conversation with
cubans you know meeting him on the
street hopping in a cab
i don't know does one guy was talking to
was a he was an industrial chemist and
he got a bit of money being a cab driver
because he could make money out of
taking foreign tourists from the airport
to the city by the way this episode is
brought to you by
delicious coca-cola
that's why i didn't want to have it on
camera but anyway no maybe they'll
actually sponsor you
i want to make sure you rotate the label
to show this is capitalism what are we
talking about here even though it's red
uh
yeah black is actually anarchist
uh i should tell you i don't know if you
know who michael malus is michael
michael malus he's a anarchist and he
lives next door he does he okay now i've
lost touch with annika's philosophy
i actually used to read you know
krapotkin and bakunin and so on and
i enjoyed their philosophy and then i
helped organize an anicus conference
once and that was the biggest antidote
possible
to being an anarchist that sounds like a
entry point to a joke
to organize it is his party it is i mean
we literally spent three days
arguing over whether there should or
should not be a chairperson for
conversations yeah
well that may be that uh
my argument life of brian was lived out
live
look at the bright side of life
all right so part of that explains why
for example even to this day in some of
those parts of the world
entrepreneurship
does not does not flourish there's not a
spirit in the people to start businesses
to launch new endeavors and all those
kinds of things
um we're just taking all kinds of
strange little strolls but how do you
explain
the mechanisms of china today
where there's
quite a bit of sort of
flourishing of businesses and so on it's
a very peculiar kind of entrepreneurship
they got away from central control
uh but it's it's but they still manage
central political control but
diversified economic control so there's
a you could it is possible to draw a
line between politics is possible and i
think in some ways china's more likely
to survive as a society going into the
future than western
uh capitalist societies are um so it's
like uh
if if we do the the karl marx the the
foreground and the background
you can um
centralized
the politics the the
the humanity
the subjective stuff
and then
uh distribute the objectives you've got
to have the goods yeah and that's what i
mean the big change from mel does deng
xiaoping was the characterized in that
little saying that i don't care whether
you have a black cat or a white cat so
long as it catches mice
and there was a level of pragmatism to
the deng xiaoping revolution over mao
and matama in particular
and that was manifest in the desire to
get as much of those western goods as
possible and i was actually in china in
81
took a group of journalists there as i
mentioned earlier for a tour we ended up
going to the sichuan free trade zone
and that gave us an idea of why
um china was going to succeed because
they had a rule
that you couldn't just come in and
exploit the cheap wages you had to also
have a chinese partner
and within five years the chinese
partner had to earn 50
of the business which is huge and it
gives you an idea of the
reduction in wages these american
corporations are looking at they'd shut
down the factory in the what's now the
rust belt of america that might be
paying somebody there you know
at that time maybe two dollars an hour
and they come across to china and
they're paying two cents an hour
so they were enormous amount of
wages that they dropped they were
willing to forego half the profits and
the ownership of the firm so what the
chinese were doing wasn't just
exploiting their labor force
it was also building a capitalist class
and that meant that you had this that's
where all the you know chinese
corporations have come from
so they were building a capitalist
system
within a socialist command political
system
and that worked
and it's still working so there was the
centralization of the economic stuff the
gauze plan approach
i think that was where the soviets
failed uh and and what the chinese
realized after what they went through
under mao
was you have to have that capitalist
period but they weren't going to abandon
the communist control politically the
country at the same time and that worked
out brilliantly and there's a huge
amount of innovation taking place in
china today
and they also will do gigantic
infrastructure projects
you know breathtaking planning going
into that if you've you would have seen
videos of you know building a skyscraper
in a day
the planning that has to go into that
the pre-preparation is necessary is
enormous so there's a real respect for
engineers as well in that society which
does not apply on the west
what do you think about the from the
western perspective the destructive
effects of centralized
control of the populace of the ideas of
the discourse of the censorship and the
surveillance all those things so and
it's a bit like we were talking about
russia to some extent beforehand uh with
centralized versus decentralized
corruption
and when you had
the centralized
political stuff means you know you can't
criticize
within china but as long as you don't
criticize you can do what you like and
how destructive is that to the human
spirit um from the american perspective
before
i've been to china quite a few times
over my life a lot in the last not for
about four years but for the six years
before that a few visits
and i'd be staying in
second and third and fourth tier cities
so you know populations of only four
million people which is quite small on
chinese standards
and
i had a lot of happy people that i was
interacting my girlfriend at the time
her social circle um and like you can
feel when people can't discuss a
political issue for example in thailand
you can't discuss the king
okay they still have you know uh less
majestic laws so you can actually be
jailed for discussing the king and you
can feel that to some extent and this is
a political issue in thailand now but in
in china what i got back from most
people it was a bit like a benevolent
big big brother
okay but then when you get things out
like the lockdown which is applied
recently then you get the
the failings of the soviet system is
still there in the chinese system in
that
the easiest way to avoid criticism
as a underling carrying out instructions
of people above you is to carry those
instructions out to the letter
beyond what the people actually want you
to do at the top
so we had a classic illustration of that
when i took these journalists
there was a news report saying that uh
china's output of light industry had
grown by 17 in the previous year but
heavy industry had fallen by seven
percent and we just did don't compute so
we kept on asking why did this happen
every time we asked a question this is
back in 81 the answer would be the
initial answer we followed the directive
to the central committee the communist
party of china
we finally got a guy to elaborate and
say what that was he said well the
central committee sent out a directive
to promote light industry so what did
you do quite unquote we stripped heavy
industry factories and turned them into
light industry yeah okay now that's
destructive of everything okay and
that's the overlay that you've still got
sitting over the top of china but a huge
part of the industrialization was simply
saying uh produce whatever you you you
can make goods market them sell them and
you get that
innovative component of humanity is
respected and the goods turn up and
everybody's well fed food in america
rush genre is far better than food in
america
so in terms of material satisfaction
uh and and freedom
really for example enjoy dancing i mean
we went to um
um i think somewhere in shanghai and
there's this line of people
involving a woman who would have been
close to her 90s and a kid who was about
six or four partying it up partying it
up in the open air and doing this
chinese collective dancing you have to
be really careful about that kind of
thing so
in terms of measuring
the flourishing of a people
by looking at their
happiness
i have so many thoughts on this but i'm
imagining north korea and if you
talk to people in north korea
i think they would say they're happy
no well let me let me let me try to
complete this argument
not an argument but a sort of
challenge to your thought
which especially in the bigger cities
because they don't know the alternative
so what else do you need there's enough
food on the table
we have a leader that loves us and we
love him
we're full of our hearts are full of
love
our table
is full of food they would say because
it's enough food
um
what else do you want from life no i
think okay like that's so let me sort of
chat because like that's an alternative
i mean i've i've one time in romania so
so let me sort of complete that sorry
because i'm taking the most challenging
when there's centralized control of
information
that you don't know the alternative
that you don't know how green the grass
is on the other side
and so your idea of happiness might be
very constrained so
you know you could also argue that is
happiness if you don't know
like ignorance is bliss ignorance is
bliss and then so is happiness really
the correct measure it's not for for the
flourishing it's not but i
i mean there's actually a classic book a
movie as well which we called mao's last
answer
okay and
that is a young man explaining his
progression from being a dancer in the
cultural revolution through to a leading
dancer in american and ultimately
australian ballet um and he
explicitly says at one point that he's
told that the chinese people have the
highest standard of living in the world
and the reaction of him and his kids
like his you know fellow six-year-old
says god it must be miserable elsewhere
in the world then okay so they knew they
still know they still know there's no
such thing as that complete ignorance
but what i'm talking about is
these experiences in china say back in
about 2016 2014
um
there was a feeling of freedom
within limits you didn't want to
transgress because the system was
working
so if you like kind of like marriage
it's kind of like marriage hey that's a
good example
there's limits there's limits that you
can have fun within those limits that's
right okay and and people did have fun
and they did feel free but they didn't
want to go and get divorced
but that dilemma
was accommodated because the boundaries
until you started hitting restrictions
were wide
okay um and like when you look at it i
mean look at the
again with the chinese communist party
the administrators of that are often
highly qualified engineers who can then
make intelligent decisions about what
should be done as infrastructure and so
on
and you go to china and you've got
incredible high-speed rail
fantastic infrastructure
internet telecommunications and so on uh
rapidly evolving solar
there's a range of things there that are
so well done
that respect reflect the fact that the
selection process that gives you your
political elite
is partially focused upon sucking up etc
etc it's still there but it's also
focused upon your
skill levels and you get people making
decisions who damn will know what
they're talking about like australia's
got a classic example the internet in
australia sucks
the reason that sucks is that the
the
labor party which is our version of the
democrats was in control during the
global financial crisis and as part of
that they wanted to bring in
optical fiber connections to the house
so you'd have an optical fiber backbone
and an optical fiber you know right to
your c100 output from your home and the
liberal party fought that and said
that's going to be too expensive
uh take too long to do we're going to do
cable to the node and then have a copper
network linking from a node on a street
to all the houses in the street it's
going to be cheaper and faster have it
more soon blah blah blah it was a total
technical fuck-up
okay and australia now has internet
that's about 50th or 60th fastest in the
world it's dreadful for the internet two
political political figures made that
decision tony abbott and and malcolm
turnbull
rivals and leaders of the um of the
conservative party we call liberal over
there now that was shitty decisions
that wouldn't happen in a country
like china because you've got actual
engineers making the decisions they say
you can't get decent speed if you link
optical fiber to copper it's gonna so
what you get is
even though you can't make the decisions
yourself
a vast majority of the decisions are
made intelligently
and therefore you expect it it's
interesting but
don't you worry about the corrupting
aspects of power oh yeah that that you
start you know you you have engineers
making intelligent decisions but at
which point
does the fat king
uh start saying oh these engineers are
annoying i have good internet i don't
understand
bring me the grapes well that
you know you get your caligular effects
that can happen like z from what i've
seen has got elements of that so friends
of mine
who who are caucasians can get away with
it they have a game that they play at
conferences scoring how often people use
with z's name in a presentation and
giving extra points for the number of
photographs of z that turn up in the
whole thing so you've got this sort of
personality cult coming along as well
but at the same time the the planning
for the infrastructure that's being
built the social services
the the general freedom that exists is
so great and like any chinese person
alive today like if somebody's chinese
my age uh was would have been an adult
under the
early period of the late period of mao
and god almighty that changed the
improvement they've seen in their lives
that's what they think about
so but it's the
if you just look at the history of the
20th century
your intuition would say that some of
the mechanisms we see in china now will
get you into trouble in the long term
so
it seems to be working really well in
many ways in terms of improving the
quality of life of the average citizen
in china
but you start to get worried about how
does this go wrong well yeah but at the
same time maybe i mean often people will
say you know what's your vision for the
future and what they mean is what vision
for the future do you have that i'm
gonna like
right okay now
what if you have a vision of the future
you don't like it's dreadful
well that's the ecological crisis i
think we're walking blindfolded into
well that's
uh right that that that part of the
picture we'll have to we'll have to talk
about yeah how fundamental of a problem
that is okay but what does that have to
do with the future of china that has to
do is that if you wish to impose
dramatic controls on the consumption of
the rich
which would be necessary to reduce our
consumption burden so that we can get
closer to the ecological envelope we've
destroyed already
then you're going to be more likely
successful doing that with a centralized
system where people accept centralized
political control
then you are in a country where it's all
diversified and you scream freedom every
between every point in a tennis match
and i'm i've literally seen that when i
was in philadelphia some time back
so the ideology that accepts a
collectivist attitude
may be more successful in controlling
our reducing human consumption levels
because when we talk about democracy i
mean
who's voting here how many horses and
elephants and
birds get to vote okay it's very what's
a bird yeah
you don't see them around here uh it's a
very human-centric vision we have of
this planet yeah and
we're going to pay a price for that
okay so you're saying to deal with
global catastrophic events
centralized planning might be maybe
i think will work better period i mean i
like but again but but there's some
centralized
stuff in the united states for example
your military yeah i know no no okay all
right
now is that now there's that feisty
australian yeah
uh so besides the military there is
that's the idea of the federal
government in the united states is that
there is some centralized uh
infrastructure building there's some big
there's not enough projects yeah
but there's some so the question is when
you deal with greater and greater global
catastrophic events
like the pandemic that we're just living
through that the government would be
able to step up
and impose enough centralized planning
to allow us to deal
sort of enable empower the citizenry to
deal with these catastrophic events
in the case of the pandemic a lot of
people argue that the
first of all the world but also in the
united states failed
to
effectively deal with a pandemic on the
medical side yeah social side and the on
the financial side the supply chain all
everything in terms of communication in
terms of
um
inspiring the populace with the power of
science and all these yeah
they failed but the ideal is that would
be able to succeed you would have to
have a small
efficient the ideal the american ideal
is you have a small efficient government
that's able to take on tasks precisely
like the pandemic but the thing is maybe
it shouldn't have been as small as it
was i mean my favorite instance of that
actually involves the uk because the
whole neoliberal approach is about a
small efficient government okay well
small efficient government works when
you face small efficient challenges
when you face something systemic
rather than episodic then it's going to
break down and like this is i mean one
of the things i greatly respect is
taleb's idea of anti-fragile you want a
society which is anti-fragile not easily
broken whereas neoliberalism has pushed
us towards this vision of efficiency but
it's easily snapped like in the uk
i've forgotten the government minister
involved but she was
she asked her expert committee how many
this is before well before the pandemic
how many masks should we have on hand in
case of a pandemic and the answer from
the experts was about a billion
okay that's 50 masks that's 20 masks per
person okay oh that's too many let's
just make 50 million masks
that's one mask per person it was gone
in a matter of a day okay and therefore
that's why they told us well masks don't
work you know what they meant was we
don't have enough masks for our health
people let alone for you and the public
so we're going to [ __ ] you until
those masks don't really work
and then people don't wear masks and
then we've got enough masks we rush up
the production job and by the time it
comes along people have got the
skepticism about masks so who does the
uh can you elaborate who does the blame
in that case go on the blame comes down
to the philosophy that says government
should always be small
no but do you do you really think that
bigger government would be the solution
to the mask issues so let me let me push
back sort of it's possible that
that that's capitalism solves that
problem
well that's not if there's no money in
really long-term planning and capitalism
okay there's money there's money in
isn't it possible to construct isn't
possible for capitalism to construct the
system
that insures against catastrophic events
not when they're systemic okay the
capital you can insure against episodic
events if you occasionally have a really
bad storm but in general the weather's
not so bad that all the infrastructure
is being destroyed then you can share
that around on a percentage basis if you
have a gaussian distribution for your
events and you can and you don't the
mean doesn't move around too much and
the standard deviation doesn't change
all that much then insurance works fine
but if you have an if that's episodic if
you have systemic stuff where the
climate is changing completely and
you're going to wipe out your
agricultural cap capabilities uh
you simply can't do insurance on that
front you you can't make a profit out of
catastrophe and capitalism
okay that's so that example of um
climate change let's talk about it okay
so you mentioned
that the human brain the economy and the
biosphere
are three of the most complex systems we
know
okay
and you also criticize
the economics community for
looking at the effects of
climate change
when measured as you know the effect on
the gdp yep so
you're saying it's a catastrophic thing
that the biggest challenge our society
our world is facing
why if the the economists disagree with
you the the effects on the gdp will be
minor
so
we'll deal with it when it comes mm-hmm
that's that's the argument against
that's the devil's advocate you're
saying no
it is
uh a thing that will change our world
forever
in ways that we should really really
really be thinking about
okay okay make the case the way you
disagree with the case is simple
economists have made up their own
numbers
to say that it's trivial and you didn't
i
no i haven't even tried to make the
numbers i'm reading what the scientists
write okay okay and what the economists
have done and like this is william
northhouse in particular nobel prize
winner ex-president of the american
economic association
literally assume that a roof will
protect you from climate change
he didn't say it in those words what he
said was 87 of american industry occurs
in carefully controlled environments
which will not be subject to climate
change now the only things that all of
manufacturing all of services included
mining as well forgetting about open cut
mining uh
government activities and the finance
sector all they have in common is they
happen beneath me for roof
so he's basically saying climate affects
the weather climate is weather okay
okay now
that is not at all what is meant by
climate change it's mean
changing the entire pattern of the
of the of the weather system of the
planet for example the most extreme form
of climate change would be a breakdown
in the three circulation cells that
exist in each hemisphere the hadley cell
the
ferrous cell i think it's called on the
polar cell 0 to 30 30 to 60 60 to 90.
those are the main
bubbles if you like in the atmosphere
now if we get enough increase in the
energy
in the atmosphere that like just like
you turn the temperature up on a stove
and you have nice bubbles occurring in a
pot of soup and then turn the
temperature up and they all break down
you've got bubbles everywhere
that's called the equitable climate if
that happens
then most of the rainfall is going to
occur between 0 and 20 and 70 and 90 and
the middle is going to be dry except for
extreme storms
we would we we built our societies in a
period of extreme stability of the
climate and when you look at the
long-term temperature records it's up
and down like a you know like a seesaw i
saw a like a sawtooth blade between say
one degree warmer than now and four
degrees or six degrees cooler over the
last million years and when you look at
where we evolved it's just at a turning
point on the peak of one of those ups
and downs so those i've forgotten the
name of the cycles but the cycles caused
by changes in the earth's rotation
around the sun uh and so
we we evolved our civilization just at
the top
so coming up from a cold period and then
we're going to head down to an another
cold period and that's when human
civilization came along it's about a
period of about 12 000 years so across
that period the temperature has changed
by not much more than half a degree up
and down now we're blasting it well and
truly out of those confines
and
my way of interpreting what
what climate change means is the
stability of that climate that enables
to build sedentary civilizations and not
be a nomadic species
is being destroyed
so the
the challenge and by the way i'm
playing devil's advocate
uh
the the question is is there something
fundamentally different now about human
civilization that we're able to
build technology
that alleviates some of the destructive
effects that we have on the climate we
don't know
and we're going to find out the hard way
and the uncertainty you think would be
very costly extremely like many of the
trajectories we might take
will be
much more costly than they're profitable
yeah
and and like
we've seen some of the storms that are
happening now in europe the ones that
you know washed away a village in
germany some time ago the the fire storm
that hit canada of all places i forgot
the name of the town that was burnt down
but an enormous temperature is in canada
uh again the storms have been happening
back in australia
these are all manifestations of a
complete shift in the weather patterns
of the planet and they can wipe out like
you know a village just disappears
because it's wiped out by unprecedented
rains and this keeps on happening
we've we've
we are still
living in a sedentary lifestyle when
we're a nomadic species okay so to be
able to maintain that sedentary
lifestyle we do need to engineer the
planet we need to keep it within that
range of plus one you know one
plus half a degree celsius minus half a
degree which is really what it's been
like for the last 10 12 000 years
instead we're blasting it right out of
that range
and
we know some of the past climates that
have existed then we can model what they
imply for our our food production
systems for example not the only example
but obviously crucial
so
when you look at what are called global
climate models produced by scientists uh
one of the examples and it was published
by the oecd last year 2021
in the chapter on what would happen if
we lose what's called the atlantic
meridional overturning circulation or
amok and people would colloquially know
that as the gulf stream and that's what
distributes heat
around all the oceans of the planet it's
part of a huge chain called the thermo
high line circulation but the part that
goes across from the um the equator to
the north atlantic that's called the a
mochan
gulfstream
colloquial way if that disappears in the
context of a two and a half degree
celsius increase in average global
temperature
then the proportion of the earth's
surface which is suitable for producing
wheat will fall from twenty percent to
seven percent
proportion for
corn similar sort of fall the proportion
suitable for rice will go from two
percent to three percent now that means
a catastrophic and that's the word used
in the report catastrophic collapse in
food production
okay so that's what we're toying with
and we are one and a half we're actually
less than about we're about halfway
there to that two degrees 2.5
and
economist on the other hand this is
richard told
okay
has published a paper 2016 claiming
using what he calls an integrated
assessment model the economists
developed
that losing the gulf stream would
increase global gdp by 1.1 percent
now that his model this is what really
pisses me off about these people is the
worst work i've read in 50 years of
being a critic of neoclassical economics
the gcms the one president presidents
produce of course include precipitation
as well as temperature
the iams that the economists produce and
this is stated yet again in a paper in
2021
do not include precipitation
they simply have temperature
so they assume that if temperature
improves by moving towards the
temperature which is better for
producing agriculture
okay then so will precipitation
now that's completely wrong they've left
out a crucial imagine trying to model
the climate while ignoring the fact that
there's rainfall
right that's what they've done so their
work is so bad
so dreadfully battered should never have
been they over all right right okay
i'm going to go for them sorry this is
well no no i want 100 as as they deserve
it so it's an oversimplification
but i also want you to steal man people
you disagree with and criticize people
you agree with if possible yeah
to be sort of intellectually honest here
you do say sort of to push back on the
catastrophic thinking about
climate change
that
the
ecology the biosphere
is a complex system yeah
economics
the economy is a complex system
so
how can we make predictions about
complex systems how can we make a hope
of
having a semi-confident predictions
about the complex system so the
scientific community is very confident
about
the complex system that is the biosphere
and the uh
the crisis that's before us on the
horizon yeah
uh and then the economists are
as a community i don't know i don't know
what percentage but
much
too much uh that part of the community
is very confident
looking at the
economics complex uh complex system
in saying that no
this
system we have
of labor and money and capital and so on
we'll be able to deal with that crisis
and any other crisis
and they kind of construct simplified
models that justify
their confidence so how do we know who
to believe well for start if you believe
the economists you you need you need
your bro your head read
because when you write an argument i
know it's not an argument it's a summary
of an argument and that is that sounds a
lot like an opinion and an emotional i
know i know i'm so angry about it like
listen i'll tell you i'll tell you where
i stand
and i've begun looking studying the
climate change yeah much more
i used to be
on things i don't
understand
have not spent time on
i have so many colleagues that are
scientists that i deeply respect
and i trust their opinion um
i have seen
the lesser angels
of my colleagues on the on the pandemic
side on the other side
the confidence the arrogance that impart
blinded i believe
the
the jump between basic scientific
research to the
uh to public policy yep yep and then
that so i've become a little bit more
cautious in my trust on climate change
i'm still in the same place
[Music]
and not i don't mean climate change and
anything scientists say i become a
little bit
wait a minute
um
how does the basic scientific facts of
our reality map to what we should do as
a human as a human civilization yeah
there i want to be a little bit careful
so whenever now i see arrogance and
confidence i become suspicious well i'm
the same and that's why i'm being angry
about the economist because there's
incredible arrogance incredible
stupidity at the arrogance
assumptions which
you look at it and think how did anybody
let that get published sure okay so
the the economic analysis of the effects
of climate change yeah are poor very
many cases incredibly poor yeah and this
is like
bjorn lomborg styles himself as the
skeptical environmentalist and
criticizes the
environmental models he doesn't take a
look he doesn't criticize the work come
out by economists you look at it it's so
bad
is it possible to do good economics
modeling of the effects of climate
change yeah it is possible uh very
difficult or is it like
one complex system stack until it's time
to in that case yeah i mean like to me
the what what you should be looking at
is saying what are the scientists saying
are the consequences probable
consequences not we're not guaranteed
but probable consequences of increasing
the energy level of the atmosphere by
the amount we're doing what can the
scientists say in terms of like
the effects because it's so complicated
the effects of
sort of shifting
resources
so basically what are the effects of
climate change how can we really model
that because it's it's basically you're
looking through the fog of uncertainty
yeah because they're rising sea levels
how can we know what effect that has
well yeah we know there'll be a lot of
change yeah this is i don't actually i
think the actual sea level one is a poor
argument and i don't focus on it what i
mainly focus upon is the the weather
patterns
okay and if you look at like we've got
the
the the wheat belt in america goes
throughout idaho and countries places
like that and you've got incredibly deep
topsoil ukraine is another classic
example the depth of the topsoil in
ukraine is remarkable and that's the
wheat bowl of europe and that requires
both the right temperature for growing
wheat and the right rainfall for growing
wheat now when we look at the models
that
climate scientists are building of of
that you have pretty much your ultimate
foundation is is the lorenz model
of turbulent flow
and of course that's that's the first
model which we saw chaos theory
complexity that beautiful simple model
three variables three parameters and
incredible complexity out of the system
uh but
and what that meant was you also had an
exponential decay in the accuracy of
your model over time so if you have if
you accurate to a thousand decimal
places
then in a thousand days you'll have no
data whatsoever because each time you're
losing an order of magnitude of accuracy
okay so that's the point about the
inability to predict for the very long
future
but what you can just say well there's a
prediction horizon if we're close enough
to the if our statistical measurement of
where we are
is close enough to where we actually are
and our forecast horizon is narrow
enough
to not extrapolate too far then for this
distance forward we can make a
reasonable fist of predicting what the
weather's going to be
and that's the foundation of
meteorological uh the stuff we watch on
tv you know that most of the time the
forecasts are going to be correct these
days 40 50 years ago most of the time
the forecasts were wrong
so that's the background foundation to
these gcms but even they've got to
massively simplify the world so you have
this enormous sphere of where they might
divide it down to 100 kilometer by 100
kilometer by 10 kilometer
cube
rectangles whatever um oblongs that
that's how they're modeling the
transition
of
where whether from one location to
another so they've got a chunky
vision of the planet which they have to
they can't model down to the last
molecule so you're losing yeah right
it's getting better and better and
better better oh yeah i think that's
that's just too much processing power
but you you're going to have some
confined you can't go i mean if you look
at the models to do the weather they
used to be of that 100 kilometer i think
about 10 kilometer grids now i don't
know but so the processing powers let us
get more and more precise that way i do
know that the models
now include chemical mixing that occurs
above cities yeah they've added that
complexity to them over time so you're
looking at the increasingly accurate
models the weather patterns the effect
they have on agriculture yeah on food
yeah and you're saying that there's a
lot of possibilities in which
that's going to be really destructive to
society and the food production side and
if you have that increase in temperature
they're going to get a change in
precipitation and it could mean that
where the rainfall and the sunshine are
adequate for growing wheat is an area
where there's no topsoil it's like a
huge part of the models the the models
the economists use which only use
temperature don't include precipitation
they predict that a large amount of the
wheat or the wheat output of the world
is going to occur in siberia
in the frozen tundra
what about so that that's a
straightforward criticism of
oversimplified models yeah what about
the idea
that we innovate our way out of it so
there's totally new
what is the there's a
a silly poor example at this time
perhaps but lab grown meat sort of
engineered
food so a completely
shifting
uh source of um
food for for civilization so therefore
alleviating some of the pressure on
agriculture that comes down to the
difference that elon makes between
between uh producing a prototype and
produce and mass producing
the prototype you can you can
develop the idea very rapidly to put
that into production
on the scale that's necessary to replace
what we're currently doing six years
yeah and we haven't got years we've got
we might have decades we certainly
haven't got centuries
um so in the time frame we've got i
can't see that engineering going from
prototype to production levels to
predict replace what we're currently
doing
in the stable environment they're
currently destroying
what do you think about the sort of the
catastrophic predictions that people
that have thought and have written about
climate have made in the past that
haven't come to that's mainly
unfortunately involving paul ellick and
the population bomb and the predictions
paul was making a few individuals or the
one individual in that case yeah so i'm
mostly playing devil's advocate yes
conversation and enjoying doing so
um
i do think
uh i'm in agreement with the majority of
the scientific community
but you still see that argument mode
i still see the argument made
and i also am a little bit worried about
the arrogance and the ineffectiveness of
the arrogance this is the problem it's
ineffective
and and that's that's what worries me
because
it's all been um
put into the sort of you know sea level
rise
um temperature changes
uh it's it's not put into the
fragility
of the system in which we
currently live
and the earth will survive and there's a
wonderful science fiction book called
the earth abides
about a world in which humans get wiped
out there's only a tiny little band left
and then the earth reasserts itself so
the earth's going to survive us will we
survive what we do with the earth that's
the question
and
my
feeling
is that
we
have underplayed the extent to which the
civilizations were built have depended
upon a relatively stable climate and
it's then there's that there's that
turning point and the maximum in the
global average temperature that we
evolved right on the top of it and if we
had done nothing
we could find that heading back down
towards another ice age could equally
destroy
the possibility of sedentary life but we
for example if we'd never developed
developed fossil fuel based industries
uh we'd never built a super phosphate so
a population would never have reached
one billion people
uh and we were still living like fairly
sophisticated animals but you know like
17th century level of load on the planet
then we would have gone down that
decline and the approaching ice age
would have started to wipe out our our
farming areas the glaciers would have
encroached and we would have been driven
out of like an agricultural sedentary
civilization by that change so it's just
the fact that we evolved
on this stable period in in the overall
temperature cycle of the planet and that
stability is something
which just reflects the turning point in
a in the regular cycle of malicious
cycle i think it's called i've forgotten
the actual name but it's a cycle caused
by
you know changing the earth's or orbit
around the sun
reflectivity and so on that that cycle
it's just that tiny top bit that we
evolved in
so what we should have done so that's
that's really useful for us we should
stay at that level
now if we hadn't done it we'd go back
down here and that would be the end of
our civilization by an ice age instead
we're going up here
really rapidly and we're causing a
change in temperature compared to that
long-term cycle 100 000 times faster
so yeah i mean my my biggest worry is uh
even subtle changes in climate
might result pressure in geopolitical
pressures
that that then lead to nuclear war and
that's yeah i mean there's an argument
that's actually behind
to some extent not the ukraine war so
much but the arab spring the wars in
syria which partially has led to what's
happening in ukraine so and our weapons
are getting more and more powerful and
more and more destructive more and more
nations are having these destructive
weapons
and now we're entering cyber
space where it's even easier to be
destructive
weapons which didn't exist in the second
world war so you know
you don't need nuclear weapons to have
you know catastrophic attacks on each
other so yeah it's incredibly scary that
that the war-like side of human nature
could be
and
extremely
enhanced by climate breakdown
so in this world
on a happy note
i don't know how we went from marxism
and stalinism to
ecology but all those are beautiful
complex systems uh
what is the best form of government
would you say on the public we talked
about the economics of things
you ran for office so you care about
politics too how can politics what
political systems can help us here i
think we first of all have to appreciate
where one species on a planet
out of
millions
and
as the intelligence species we should be
enabling a harmonious
life
for those other species as well can we
actually linger on that what is
you mentioned we need to acknowledge the
value of life on earth
you know can we integrate
uh
the labor theory of value
can we integrate into that the value of
life
um so there's human life i i think
if you if you take like that structure
that i talked about of marx's use value
exchange value
dialectic the foreground background that
only exists that only works because
we're exploiting the free energy we find
in the universe
there could be no production system
without free energy which is a
you know the first law of thermodynamics
there is free lunch withdrawal and it's
grounded in the energy that's provided
to us but well yeah that's the free
launch that's what we're expecting
you know ginsberg summary of the laws of
thermodynamics don't you allen ginsberg
said the the the the laws of
thermodynamics summarized a you can't
win
okay b you can't break even
yep see you can't leave the game
nice yeah beautiful summary a beautiful
summer okay uh but the fact that exists
in the first place is the free lunch
okay so we're exporting the free lunch
but to be able to do it we can't put
waste back into that system so much that
it undermines the free lunch and that's
what we've been doing
and once you respect the fact that we
have to
living on on the biosphere the planet
we're actually on
we have to enable that biosphere to
survive us
because if it doesn't survive us we
won't survive it disappearing and
there's not that realization in humanity
in general and when you see the value of
life
you know all the different living
organisms on earth are part of the
biosphere yeah
so in order to maintain
the biosphere we have to
respect like
pragmatically speaking what that means
is actually respecting all of life on
earth even the mosquitoes
uh i've got some of them no
diaper parasites i mean we are a
parasite when you look at it we're the
mosquitoes of the huma of the the large
organizations you have you're a fan of
the matrix movies at all sure okay you
know the scene where i look what i'm
wearing absolutely i was wondering what
the inspiration was i was thinking about
really inspiration
we are living in a simulation okay and i
have a conversation offline to have with
you about that okay we've been
misbehaving and we're gonna have to put
you back in line so what what's agent
smith says when he's got uh
morpheus in his possession he said i've
been trying to classify your species
i've decided you're a virus
okay now there's truth that we have
intruded into everything okay we've
taken over every element of the of the
biosphere
and and we think we can continue doing
that
the thing is we're breaking that
we're exporting it so much we're
breaking it down and yeah i think a ceo
wilson who argued with the 50 rule he
believed that we should reserve 50 of
the planet
for non-human species in other words we
make 50 of it off limits humans cannot
go there
and we just let that evolve as it does
and then we control the other 50 i think
it's probably giving too much to us
i think we should actually save like 20
25 max and the rest of the planet
we let life go on and evolve as it does
without our interference without our
dominance
now
that's neither a dometic democratic
system nor an authoritarian one it's one
which starts off with saying we the
first thing humans have to do is respect
life itself
okay so
would we do that
we haven't done it obviously i don't
think the soviets would have done it if
we had a generally soviet system we
haven't done under capitalist uh we
continue intruding so we we i think we
have to go through something like a star
trek a star trek you know catastrophic
200 years
to realize that ultimately if we're
going to survive as a species we have to
respect life in general and then that
means we parts of parts of the planet we
can no longer touch
while we also try to maintain the planet
at the temperature that we found it in
what we now call the anthropocene
okay
so
politically
we have to have
like in in many ways what native
societies often have a vision of the
cycle of life not this
exponential progression we've developed
over the last 250 years
um and again i'll use another movie the
avatar type respect for the cycle of
life
we need to have that as part of our
innate nature and then on top of that
the political system comes out now that
political system has to be one that lets
us feel like we have a say in
the direction of society while that part
is sacrosanct okay we can't touch it
but we also because we are now living
with so many challenges created by our
own civilization i mean the main threat
to the existence of human civilization
is the existence of human civilization
it's both a feature and a bug yeah and
therefore
we need to have people who can
understand complex systems making those
decisions now that means it isn't a
political system as much as it is
an appreciation that the world is a
complex system and therefore
effects which we think a direct effect
will actually come through an oblique
fashion
and we cannot
there's no simple linear progression
from where we are to where we want to be
so you have to see how everything feeds
together in a systemic way and that's
why well one reason i designed the
software i'm wearing the t-shirt for now
minsky is to have it's nowhere near
to this scale i hope it one day will be
but something which means we can bring
together all that complexity all those
systems and perceive them on an enormous
screen where we have all the various
interacts and we can see what are
potential futures and
and that then
guides us so it isn't a case of
democracy and you know
our side wins the vote and therefore we
ban abortion or we don't you know
whatever else happens it's
seeing what the
respecting the fact that we're in a
complex system and being uncertain about
the consequences and not making the
bold uh expansionary
ideas that we've been doing
so like being a little bit more and so
uh
humble
humble humble is a good word but
wouldn't you
like to apply that same humility both
to the considerations of
the the uh the pros of capitalism and
and to the catastrophic view of the
effects of climate change yeah and also
like i think we can we can afford to be
bold in space
and that's one reason i respect the
practical vision of musk and so far
impractical vision of bezos
that if we're going we look for the very
far future
the only way we can continue expanding
our knowledge of the universe is to move
our civilization
the productive side of off the planet
off-site backup yeah
so can you actually linger on this so
let's actually talk about this so first
of all you have the new book
uh humbly naval uh named the new
economics
a manifesto publisher chose the title
yes no but i'm joking but um
maybe i will ask you about why manifesto
but we'll go through some of the ideas
in this book we have been already uh
so some of it is embracing the fact that
the economy
our world our mind is the complex system
so this t-shirt that you're wearing yep
second out yep is uh the software
i'll do that do you like it
there you go you're wearing them
okay that's just infomercial
so there's a t-shirt that says minsky
um after
not not not my minsky it's german
yeah so no they're heimann minsky not uh
marvin means not marvin right so
that's so a.i minsky ismar and then uh
harmon
it all rhymes
so stability is
free open source
system dynamics software
invented by
mr steve keane
coded by russell standish that's on
sourceforge
it's destabilizing ability is
destabilizing so that's sort of
embracing the the complex
aspect of it yeah so how can you model
the economy what are some of the
interesting
well they're detailed or high level big
picture ideas behind
your efforts with minsky okay minsky
meaning the software the modeling
software the that models the dynamics
basically what minsky is doing is system
dynamics modeling so it's if anybody's
used stella or ven sim or simulink um
then they've used exactly the same
family of software that minsky is part
of so i didn't invent that that was
invented by jay forrester who's one of
the great intellects one of the great
engineers
in american history and the idea of of
forrester's system was
complex interactions so he was doing his
work in the 50s um uh he if people don't
don't know forrester's work he actually
built the models of the um uh the
mathematics for the gun turrets on
american warships in the second world
war mechanical systems obviously
so he had to work out a you know
how to give a feedback system that meant
when the boat rolled in one direction
the turret did not roll the other way
all that stuff was his work so marvelous
engineering and then he realized if you
want to look at a even like a factory a
factory is a complex system and so you
get cycles generated out of the
interaction between
different components of the factory that
he was first involved in taming that he
built the software to model complex
interactive systems so minsky is that
the thing at minsky adds which is unique
is the godly table and that's the double
entry bookkeeping so you can model the
financial system godly the economist
godly the economy win godly another
great great man so there there's like
this so you you're modeling as it's like
a state diagram yeah fundamentally so
it's actually this is circuit diagrams
it's exactly what engineers have been
using for
decades almost a century uh so you're
using a circuit diagram to model the
economy and that's that's the
so other packages have done it what
they've what they haven't had in the
circuit diagram is a way of handling the
dynamics of the financial system so what
the godly table does is bring it um
financial flows as being uh
everything goes from somewhere and ends
up somewhere
so you have a positive and a negative if
you're looking on the liability side
uh a positive and a positive or negative
and a negative you're looking at assets
and liabilities aside and minsky gets
the accounting right for that so you can
do an enormous complex model
looking at the economy financially from
the point of view of a dozen different
actors in the economy and know that the
mathematics is right even though what
you're building a set of differential
equations which might be 50 differential
equations with 350 terms in them if you
get the godly tables right you know the
mathematics is correct so that's the
main innovation that minsky adds and
you're operating there at the
macroeconomics level yeah it's
definitely macro it's top down it's not
it's not agent-based and then this i'm
just opening on a random page that i
think is very relevant here uh the
process this is referring to minsky not
the software maybe the software i don't
know the process can be captured in an
extremely simple causal chain capital
determines output alpha determines
employment the rate of employment
determines the rate of change of wages
output minus wages and interest payments
determines profit the profit rate
determines the there's a very nice
circuit here yeah the profit rate
determines the level of
investment which is the change in
capital which takes us back to the
beginning of this causal chain and the
difference between investment and
profits determines the change in private
debt and there's some nice
uh the kinminski model and the
intermittent route to chaos on page 86
of your book these are did these come
from the software yeah yeah i mean i
first did that in mathematica uh back in
1992 august 1992.
uh mathematics is another amazing piece
of software yeah and i find it it's very
much a programmer's approach to
mathematics i prefer like a program
called mathcad
which is what i'm using for all my uh
when i do my mathematics on the
computer i write math cad or cab cad
okay it's been ruined by a bad
management they chucked out all the good
engineers and i'm still using a version
which is 12 years old if all the
engineers ruled the world
if only engineers rather than this
particular case there was a bunch of
marketers for cad software agreed
i'm definitely a fan of engineers what
are the plots that we're looking at here
growth rate private debt ratio
employment versus wages employment
versus debt income distribution so what
this is across years like different
trade-offs yeah is there something
interesting to say about the plots and
the insights from those plots that yeah
yeah and software that's um that's
particular parameter values to give that
outcome but
what happened when i first simulated the
model i took a model by a guy called
richard goodwin who's one of the great
neglected economists
american marxist mathematical marxist
and what he did was build a model of
cycles and he he actually wrote a paper
called um
it's only about a five-page paper
published in a in a book and a very very
obscure conference paper and what he was
doing was trying to build a model of
marx
okay so if you he wrote it in 1967 and
it was putting in a mathematical form of
model that marx came up with an 1867. so
it was a centenary birthday present to
marx and what marx had argued in
chapter
25 i think
of volume 1 a capital section 3.
he um
he
built a verbal model of a cyclical
system and it's quite out of character
with the rest of the book so when you
read volume 1 of capital people think
marx has got a commodity money
view of money he doesn't at all he
simply did the idea was he had like an
onion do you start off on the middle
level and you ignore the outer layer
then you bring the outer layer and so on
and so forth anyway in this model in in
volume on a capital he normally just
assumed workers got a subsistence wage
that's it but in this little chapter he
said
that if um
if the
economy is effective his economy is
booming
then workers will demand wage rises
okay and the wage rises will cut into
the profit
so that capitalists will not get the
level of profit they're expecting
therefore they will invest less and the
economy will slump and the slump will
mean workers
become unemployed and have to accept
wage cuts and it was a model of a
cyclical economy and as it happens mark
spent his later years trying to learn
enough calculus to be able to model it
himself mathematically and he never
managed there's marx's and mathematical
notes on calculus which are quite fun to
read and if you have a mathematical
background did he get far
no he got too caught up in the whole
philosophy and he never really got to
build the model but what what um goodwin
realized was a predator prey model
okay the lock the volterra model was the
basis of the idea say what the idea is
you have a have a prey like a and the
example that that lochter actually used
initially was grass
grasses the prey and then you have a
predator and the predator cows
so you start off with a very few cows
lots of grass and then because of lots
of grass the numbers of cows grow
and then because the cows grow they
start to eat the grass so the grass runs
out so the cows starve and you get a
cycle and what lochter was amazed by was
that the cycles were persistent they
they didn't die out so goodwin got that
vision and he then built a predator-prey
model and i first of all read goodwin
and really found it really hard to
follow his writing it was
he's not a very good writer but a guy
called john blatt who was a professor of
mathematics at new south wales
university wrote a brilliant explanation
of the goodwin's model in a book called
dynamic economic systems and i read that
it was superb and he said a way you
could extend this was to include finance
so i thought okay what i'm going to have
is that what
goodwin presumed is capitalists invest
all their profits
okay so you get a boom when they're when
there's a high rate of profit because
they invest all that money and then a
slump when there's low profit because
depreciation will wipe away capital and
you'll go boom and slump so i simply
added in well capitalists will invest
more than their
profits during a boom
but less than their profits during a
slump
and that therefore means they had to
borrow money to finance the gap and pay
interest on the debt so i ended up with
a model with just three system states
the
income share the wages distribution of
income from workers capitalists and
bankers
the level of employment and the level of
private debt
and those three equations
are fundamentally like going from the
luck to volterra model with just two
equations and therefore you get a fixed
cycle
to the lorenz model where you have three
and therefore what i got out of it was a
chaotic outcome so what you're seeing is
a
manifestation of chaos
complexity in that those plots but the
fascinating one of the many fascinating
parts about it was that
as the level of private debt rose
i eve in my model i had capitalists
being the only ones who borrowed
but the people who paid for the higher
level of private debt were the workers
the rising bankers share
corresponded exactly to a falling
workers share
so you're you can infer from that that
the workers are the ones paying
effectively the workers end up paying
for it they get a lower level of wages
and it's the basic dynamic is that
capitalists
when you have a three social class
system your income goes between workers
capitalists and bankers now in the
system that goodwin did they're just
workers and capitalists so if workers
share rose profit capital share had to
fall okay but when you have three social
classes then capital share can remain
constant while workers fall in bankers
workers falls and bankers rise so that's
what actually happened uh because
capitalists the simple way i modeled it
was there's a certain rate of profit at
which capitalists invest all their
profits above that they borrow more
below that they pay off debt
so what would happen is when you got
back to that point
then the level of investment would be a
precise share of gdp
and therefore you get a precise rate of
economic growth but if there was a
higher percentage going to bankers
and offset by a lower share going to
workers it didn't affect the capitalists
so what you get is the cycles sort of
diminish for a while because
uh there's
as
so the income distribution effect is
important so the
the workers pay for the increasing level
of debt
but the other side of it was that the
cycles were diminished for a while now
what you get is a period of diminishing
cycles then leading to rising cycles and
technically this is known as the uh
pomenova
route to chaos and it's one particular
element of lorenzo's equations of fluid
dynamics so what they found was in
examining
laminar flow and a fluid you have a
period where the laminar flow got more
laminar and then suddenly it would start
to get less laminar and go turbulent
and this is this is what actually goes
on in the model so in my model of minsky
so
what you have is a period where there's
big berms and cycles and then as the
debt level rises the booms and slums get
smaller and that looks like what
neoclassical economists call the great
moderation
so i when i first modeled this 1982 i
finished up my paper which is published
in 95 with what i thought was a nice
rhetorical flourish saying the the
chaotic dynamics of this paper should
warn us against regarding a period of
relative stability in a capitalist
economy as anything more than a lull
before the storm
now i thought it was a great speed of
rhetoric i didn't think it was going to
[ __ ] happen but it did because you
had this period from 1990 through to
2007
where there were diminishing cycles and
the neoclassicals labelled that the
great moderation and they took the
credit for it they thought that the
economy was being managed by them to a
lower rate of infla inflation a lower
level of unemployment less instability
over time and they literally took credit
for it and i was watching that and
thinking that's like my model running
and i'm sure i'm scared of [ __ ]
that there'll be a breakdown i ended up
not um working in the area for a while
because i wrote debunking economics
and i got involved in a fight over the
modeling of
competition in neoclassical theory that
took me away for about four or five
years
and then i got asked to do a court case
in 2005 end of 2005
and
i used minsky as my framework for
arguing that somebody who was involved
in predatory lending should be able to
get out of the debt they were in
and i explained minsky's theory and i've
used this
throwaway line of saying debt levels
have been private debt have been rising
exponentially
and then i thought well i can't as an
expert just make a claim like that i've
got to check the data
and the debt ratio was rising
exponentially and i thought holy [ __ ]
we're in for a financial crisis
and somebody has to warn about it at
least in australia i was that somebody
so can you given this chaotic dynamics i
idea can you talk about the crisis ahead
of us in the future so one of the things
i mean it's fun about the question of
economics
is economics about understanding the
past or predicting the future
because uh
you can construct models that
do poetic like in 95
poetic um
yeah and then you can you know watch
years come fly by and some of the
predictions in retrospect that you make
turn out to be true but you you know you
all kinds of gurus throughout history
have done that kind of thing
um and you can call yourself right and
forget all the many times you've been
wrong
let's talk about the future what kind of
stuff
you mentioned about the importance of
the biosphere
but what other crises are ahead of us
that this that that a chaotic dynamics
view
allows us to predict really i saw coming
out of it
leaving aside the ecological
wasn't a crisis it was stagnation
because what we got out of the crisis
was caused by a rising level of private
debt
okay now you reach a peak level where
the willingness to take on debt
collapses
and so you go to a period where debt is
rising all the time so credit which is
the annual change in debt
and that's credit is part of aggregate
demand and aggregate income so credit
goes from positive to negative and that
causes a slump so that would uh so can
you describe why that causes this lump
credit goes to negative if you ask paul
krugman he'll tell you credit plays no
role in aggregate demand
okay give me a second uh credit plays no
role in an aggregate demand
so the vision the vision that the
neoclassicals have for the banking
system is what they call learnable funds
is paul krugman by the way the uh
the knight
at the front of the army that is the
neoclassical economist
yeah fundamentally sure okay um
he he's he's politically reasonable
which makes him
more dangerous than those that aren't
he's politically there's quite a lot of
people that would disagree with that
characterization of paul krugman as he's
politically reasonable you should see
the people
okay okay
fair enough okay
that's not a negative or positive
statement that's just he can be feisty
as well he can he can but he's like the
human face of neoclassical economics
he doesn't deserve having a human face
it's a anti-human theory but you really
think i got you all right well so
yeah uh so but the credit does not have
any effect on aggregate demand in their
model and you're saying that's not the
case it's absolutely crucial to
aggregate demand so what they model is
again the example of you lending to me
or vice versa if i lend money to you i
can spend less you can spend more okay
so
credit credit is the change in debt so
if there's if i lend money to you then
there's a level of private debt rises
okay so there's an increase in credit
but that increase in credit comes at an
expense of my spending power so you can
spend what i've lent you but i can't
spend what i've lent you so credit
cancels out but when you look at that's
learnable funds but in the real world
and the bank of england has said this is
the real world and the textbooks are
wrong categorically in
2014.
when the bank lends it adds to its asset
side and says you owe us more money and
it adds to its liability site and says
here's the money in your bank account
now you spend that money so what happens
when you do your sums credit is part of
aggregate demand and aggregate income
and that's something i first solved in
2019 i think
2000 so i only recently proved it
mathematically so what that means is
credit
can is a component of aggregate demand
and credit is also very volatile it's
like consumption demand never goes
negative
investment demand never goes negative
but credit can go from positive to
negative and when you take a look at the
long run of american history after the
second world war
there was no period uh until 2007
where credit was negative it was a
positive component of g d
a positive number
therefore when you do it as a percentage
of gdp it was a positive percentage of
gdp
it peaked at 16
of gdp in 2006 2007 it fell to minus
five percent in 2008 2009 so you had a
20 of gdp
turn around in aggregate demand
now when you plot that against
unemployment the correlation of
credit to unemployment
across the period from about 1990 to
2010
is about minus 0.9
okay
enormous negative correlation now
according to the neoclassicals it should
be close to zero
empirically it's bleedingly obvious it's
not and it applies to every country in
the world that had a financial crisis at
that period so
it's it's bleedingly obvious in the data
and they ignore it because credit's not
part of their model
and you're saying it's causation that's
what it's called
today we said there is extremely high
inflation
what
does inflation
what role does inflation play in this
picture is a little bit of inflation
good we talked about money creation
um and at the beginning
what's a little bit of inflation good or
bad a lot of inflation good or bad how
concerned
again it's taken me a while to get my
head around around this but if you think
about how people say what are the
functions of money they say money it's a
unit of count account yeah you're
measuring it's a means of exchange okay
and it's a store of value
okay now
yes okay it has those three roles but
the last one is contradictory of the
previous two
because and this is where we see this
with the bitcoin phenomenon
if you want to hang onto money as a
store of value
then
if prices are falling
the value of money is rising
and it's actually in your interests as a
store of value to hang on to it and not
spend it okay
so that contradicts its role as a means
of exchange
now if you have money which depreciates
and this was actually tried in this in
the austrian town of wargle during the
second before during the great
depression
if you have money that depreciates then
if you don't use it you lose it
fundamentally so it has a high rate of
circulation so there's a
a monetary theorist called silvio
gazelle
and he wrote this proposal that money
should depreciate
and he was a
ridicule and opposed and derided but
kane said he was a great intellect
and the mayor of town of wargle
in austria during the great depression
was facing an unemployment rate you know
25 percent pretty much the germany had
the worst experience in the great
depression in the world which was as bad
as america slightly worse than america
and so he thought how can i stimulate
demand here so he produced a script
which could only be used for buying
goods and services in wargle
and
and could be used to pay your local
rates but it was depreciated by putting
a stamp on the money if you didn't use
it so what happened was people would pay
their rates they needed to pay the rates
using this money so the the script so
they use the script and it because it
depreciated you'd use it rapidly so
people were using that money this
alternative to the austrian shilling and
the economic activity in town took off
and unemployment fell to zero and it was
an absolute miracle and if you loved a
wargle experiment and the austrian
central bank sued them
for establishing an alternative form of
money and shut it down
unemployment went back up to 25 again
and austria voted you know what 99 point
was it 99.6
for the nazis something crazy number
like that one when hitler marched in so
the wargle experiment showed that a
depreciating currency led to a high rate
of circulation but of course we're not
talking by my republic levels of
inflation so when you get that much
inflation and that's normally caused by
as the as the as the weimar inflation
was caused by the reparation terms
imposed on germany
fundamentally by france at the 3d
versailles
they
paid a large part of that with just
basically printing the notes and he went
into this crazy period of hyperinflation
so hyperinflation almost always occurs
when there's a massive destruction of
physical resources and the monetary
authority tries to pay back literally
over it and then you get hyperinflation
that's total social breakdown so a
moderate level of inflation
inspires the means of exchange usage of
money that undermines the store of value
usage of money
and
and that dilemma is why we have this
antagonistic attitude towards inflation
yeah i mean you're describing his
attention
but
it's nevertheless is like money is a
store of value and a means of exchange
and i don't
you know
to push back it's not necessarily that
there's attention it's just that
depending on the dynamics of this uh
beautiful beautiful economic system of
ours it's used as one more than the
other if there's inflation you're using
it more
for the
means of exchange
it's deflation using more for store
value but that doesn't i don't see it as
a tension that's just the uh
how much you use it for those different
like but a bit ends up saying that
overall the level of effective commerce
a bit of inflation is a good thing
because that's depreciating the money
slightly and encourage its use yeah but
so the argument that
uh some bitcoin folks use or gold
standards
again huddle's not an argument
uh
is that
having an inflation of zero
is actually achieving that balance
yeah right so like that yeah but they're
actually in favor of negative they
wanted to appreciate rapidly and there's
addictively negative inflation that the
value of the value of the money rising
relative to commodities that's what they
want that's the hotel philosophy
well that's more of like an investment i
don't know if that yeah that's more of
an investment philosophy than the
fundamental principles of why they
believe in
cryptocurrency and
enforce scarcity it's a model the
concern there is that when you print
money
the public
policies detached from the actual
um
from value
yeah well you get i mean this is this is
where again it matters to get money
creation right because the government's
not the only money creator banks are as
well private banks
and
and we if we obsess too much about
limiting government money creation
what we end up getting if there is money
creation going on the private banks
doing it and you get an increase in
private debt and fundamentally private
debt and its collapse
uh
types of credit when it stops growing
that's the fundamental cause of
financial crises
so yeah but the question is what's the
the cause for the the collapse of the
uh well i think this is like the
austrian thinking leaves out the debt
deflation and that's like i think one of
the most important papers ever written
was by irving fischer called the debt
deflation theory of great depressions
fischer was somebody who
accepted the neoclassical vision he
wrote the
pre-efficiency market hypothesis
efficiency market hypothesis he had a
his his own phd called the theory of
interest
and in that he argued effectively for a
supply and demand analysis of the of the
um financial system
and he argued for equilibrium
he said when you're working with a like
a commodity market then the sale and the
uh
the transaction and the exchange occur
at the same point in time
when you're working with the financial
market then the exchange occurs through
time
so he's he said he assumed that debts
are repaid
all debts are repaid and he assumed that
equilibrium through time was an
essential part of his assumption this is
and then the great depression comes
along
and he
has become a major shareholder in rank
xerox
because he invented the rolodex
he's a tinkerer and so he had taken out
shares
on margin and he was worth about 100
million in modern terms
when the great depression hit and 90 of
that was share market valuation he'd
taken out margin debt just like
everybody else
and with margin debt you could put down
a hundred thousand dollars and buy a
million dollars worth of shares
so you got this huge leverage into debt
now that when the financial crisis hit
the level of margin debt in america had
risen from half a percent of gdp in 1920
to 13 of gdp
in 1929 it then fell to zero again
that's why the stock market crash in 29
was so devastating that scale of of
margin lending
and everyone was being wiped out they
were selling rolls-royces for 20 quid
you know that you literally have
photographs showing people doing that
because a margin call comes in you've
got to liquidate everything
okay so he said the danger is is is of a
debt deflation is what we have to avoid
okay and that means
you don't want too much private debt to
accumulate
and you don't want
falling prices because the falling
prices will amplify
the impact of being insolvent to begin
with
and that's what we saw in the great
depression it's partially what we saw in
2007 but we didn't have anything like
the level of of margin debt margin debt
was reduced from 90 to 50 ratio after
the great depression
um so there were limits on how bad it
was in 2007
but
the danger is still the period of
deflation amplifies your debts
okay and he's he i call it fisher's
paradox he didn't write those terms
himself but he wrote a line saying the
more debtors pay the more they owe okay
and this is because you're liquidating
to try to
meet your own debts
when you liquidate the price level falls
you will end up having a lower level of
monetary debt but a higher level of debt
when you deflate it using the price
level so the biggest danger in
capitalism is the debt deflation
far more dangerous than inflation and
the cause of debt deflation is
too much lending too much bank lending
too much private money creation
and if you take a look at the 1920s
calvin coolidge
explained the boom of the 1920s on his
surplus he said my government running a
surplus of 1 of gdp pretty much from
1922 through to 1930
is the foundation of our stability it
should be continued what he didn't look
at was that over that same time period
on average americans were borrowing five
percent of gdp per year from the private
banks
so you had a housing bubble at the
beginning of the 1920s which richard
vague covers beautifully in the
brief history of doom
and then you had this huge rise in
margin debt as well gigantic increase in
margin debt
so all this borrowed money was being
spent into the economy and this is where
credit becomes part of aggregate demand
and it's both not just for goods and
services it's also for shares and houses
and so on so a huge valuation effect
but then when the margin debt turned
around when people would not take out
margin debt anymore the demand for
margin debt disappeared and then it was
a you know what we call badly a positive
feedback loop is actually an amplifying
feedback loop and that calls to collapse
so
what elements of that do you see today
that we need to fix and how do we fix it
we have to regard the level of private
debt as a
target of economic policy just as much
as the rate of inflation or the rate of
unemployment how do wha what is the
moderate amount of private debt that's
good i would say something of you
anywhere between 30 and 70 percent of
gdp
what is it currently uh in america it's
170 percent
nice
of gdp of gdp oh that's for nice i've
got that
after we talk but i can show you the the
data in this and it's
it it is just this huge increase in
private debt yeah the cause first of all
caused the boom
but then financing the credit causes
ultimately causes the slump and so if we
remove the
rate level at which debt can reach and
we stop speculative lending and base
heavily lending for both uh innovation
invest investment and
essential consumption items we won't
have the slump on the other side we can
we can get rid of financial instability
we can't stop financial cycles but we
can stop financial breakdown and so we
should really be focusing on the
instability and getting that yeah
by the way as you point your laptop uh
my laptops i have a lot of
how many computers do i have but a lot
of them but my little surface whatever
the heck this thing is is getting
definitely size envy because your laptop
you said is eighteen something point
four inches eighteen point four inches
um
you know i don't think i've ever seen
one that big and i'll give the internet
that one
all right um that's for the graphics so
it's the gaming laptop it's just the
desktop
it probably weighs like 40 pounds
you have to
eight kayla's
eight kilos let's see if you like an
idol
oh wow okay yeah okay eight kilos uh
that's you know you're seeing the power
supply for it it's over there somewhere
the power supply weighs about twice as
much as your laptop yeah and it you have
to power it on with the crank pretty
close to like pause
is it gas powered or is it coal or oh
well
it's a nuclear power station yeah and
nuclear diamond in the back then
okay so um
let me before i forget just let me ask
you about
we've we've covered brilliantly the the
the nuance disagreements you have and
the wisdom you've drawn from karl marx
but there's also
um like you mentioned in popular
discourse
um
a kind of a distorted use of different
terms and one of them is marxism yeah
today is there something you can just
speak to about
you know increased
use of that word and is it misused does
it concern you that there's a lot of
actually young people that say they're
sort of proudly marxists
uh
are they misusing the term they are
definitely misusing the term if they
don't understand
the use value exchange value dialectic i
went through earlier uh so so if i don't
if i could just pause the idea of
socialism
and marxism is used in sort of popular
lingo yeah it's basically
you know um a lot of people have a
disproportionately hard life why can't
we help them out
why can't we be kind to our fellow man
kind of that's that's
a short embodiment of an idea as opposed
to some
super complicated uh elaborate
model of the economy and politics
i mean we could do that by using the
insights that come out of modern
monetary theory which i've confirmed
just using my simple minsky models and
that is that to use the term usually a
feature not a bug
a government running a deficit is a
feature
of a well-functioning
mixed fiat credit economy not a bug the
government should normally run a deficit
because that's how the government
creates money now because we've had this
obsession from mainstream economists
running a surplus which is what caused
the great depression calvin cool is
doing it for eight years because of that
obsession we've cut back on social
services we've cut back on health we've
cut back on education we've cut back on
infrastructure now all that stuff
predominantly affects the poor because
the rich can afford to buy it themselves
so if we had a sonoma to realize the
government should run a deficit it's a
feature not a bug of a fiat money system
and that's where eons made one mistake
recently okay we're not going back to
first principles that deficit enables
you to provide an enough
of a decent standard of living for those
who don't come out on top and the
the capitalist game
and with that you wouldn't have the
angst of the young people now we still
have the climate
parameters within which we have to
survive but a decent level of government
funding would mean the yanks that you
get where people say i want to be a
marxist
and they've got what i call a cardboard
cutout version of marks in their minds
that wouldn't be happening
so it's it's potential to have a good
society where the government runs a
deficit that finances the the needs of
the poor where the rich get enough to
you know indulge and take care of
themselves
and you you don't get this breakdown if
you if you try to cause the government
running a surplus then the burden of
that is borne by the poor
middle class and poor and that will lead
to the angst we're now seeing
beautiful that was uh
that was a beautiful
whirlwind exploration of all economics
and economics history let me ask you
what you tweeted i think yeah uh we are
the opposite of ants individually
intelligent
collectively stupid
we need to develop systems thinking fast
to counter our limitations
um
that's really interesting do do you
really believe we're individually
intelligent and collectively stupid i do
how can you elaborate on i mean some of
that is just cheeky tweets but it was it
was
it's cheeky tweet i've had in my mind
for a long time just it's one that
actually went moderately viral not
enough but moderately viral for me um
but nevertheless what if you could
analyze it as if it's some deep profound
thing you made in a book well the reason
is that we are like incredibly
individually intelligent things like
these devices we're playing with now
that's the creation of individual minds
creative individual mind and a
collective labor over centuries that led
to this level of technology and that has
to be respected it's in incredible stuff
uh but at the same time i think what
humans are
if you want to distinguish humans from
other species on the planet we don't
weave webs
okay
uh we don't make bird calls what we do
is we share beliefs
yeah okay now you don't think that's
awesome that's a
you don't think that's a catalyst for
intelligence yeah it is a catalyst but
what it means is
uh we can delude ourselves as much as we
can inform ourselves
so
because we share beliefs we can do
things in a collective way
and if we believe that you know we can
if we take the incantations of the witch
doctors and we
and we happen to have a couple of spears
and and things we can go and attack the
local
uh hurt a tribe of
lions and drive them out and we become
the dominant species so it worked at the
stage where we were
in competition with other species on the
planet now that we're the dominant
species
then our beliefs get in the way
so you agree with uh with einstein who
said uh the only
there are only two things that are
infinite the universe and human
stupidity and he wasn't sure about the
universe and he wasn't sure about the
right
that's right and he wasn't sure about
the universe
uh
yeah so you think that the collective i
mean
there's an affinity to the destructive
and the
the stupid the inhumane that's possible
when we humans get together but it feels
like
there's more trajectories there's more
possibility for creation there are and i
think that's why we have to
i say if we if we built around the idea
that our
role as a species is to maintain and
extend life
on the planet and and if not find it
elsewhere then
seated elsewhere yeah then that is a
vision which makes us creative and
confines the worst elements of our
capacities to share beliefs
so i that's what i my hope is
that we'll reach that stage but i think
we've overshot it so badly
that my real fear is we'll end up
blaming technology
for the
type of world we find ourselves living
in in the next 20 to 50 years so you
think technology is going to be one of
the
part of the solution part of the
solution yeah but it's but
if we go through and blame it which is
quite possible yeah we'll blame the
technology rather than blaming too much
of the technology and the too much comes
down to what economists have told us
that we can just continue consuming
infinitely on a finite planet and
kenneth bolding said that beautifully
said the
if somebody believes that he can have
exponential growth on a finite planet
they're either mad or they're an
economist
so you're uh you made a long journey for
which i'm deeply honored from
from um sydney
this distant place activities there's
myth you've got to go there one day
you'd enjoy it i will i'm afraid if if i
go there i will stay forever and so no
it's a bit too you know this there's
more vitality back in this economy so
you'd come back
okay maybe you know i'm not a fan of the
economy or money or any of that nature
calls me
let me uh so i'm i'm honored that you
make that trip you've also said that you
while you're here in austin you're going
to um
go to uh
this american factory
uh that makes cars
here in austin and also visits starbase
so let me ask you about
expanding out into the universe is that
something that
that excites you yeah i mentioned about
the economics of it do you think um
does it
what do you think marx would think about
this like what economically
speaking what what is this is it a good
thing
i i think it's vital we can have
capitalism and outer space
far more successfully than we can have
it on the planet because we don't face
when we dump the waste ends up in the
sun not a problem okay um
so it means the potential we don't
undermine our own productive capacity if
we're doing it in outer space so the
destructive element of waste is uh has a
lesser impact in this car yeah i mean
who cares if we throw a bit of our iron
back into the sun again and take a fair
bit of it to turn it into a what would
be the next stage to be a red giant um
and we have to get away because if
there's a red giant at some stage it'll
the sun will head out past the orbit of
mars i think certainly past the orbit of
earth
so
to have the longevity of
just human life
the life that evolved on this planet we
have to be able to take it off planet
ultimately so if you think in the really
long term
then it's our responsibility we're going
to maintain life is to get is to
establish life off the planet
what do you think about robots and ai
part of the expanding our interviews oh
yeah we have to i mean you that's that
that ends labor you can't be you can't
go for it you know you're deadly jean
can't be from here to the asteroid belt
and back again for dinner with your
family uh so with production would be
entirely mechanized there'd be have to
be a handful of people who service the
machines but so it's about production
and automation what about
elements of consciousness that make
humans so special
what about that persisting within them
that i mean i'm still a skeptic about as
ever being able to create a machine
which is truly conscious if i can throw
my it's almost two cents that would
really piss off karl marx by the way if
we create machines that are conscious
exactly this is actually part of the
there's two good logical arguments
against the labor theory of value one of
what it becomes machines become
intelligent and the other was the if the
declining rate of profit applies in
socialism
it'll apply as a rate of accumulation
and sorry in capitalism it'll apply as a
rate of socialism as well a guy called
khalid made that argument so his
argument was just unsound but yeah
intelligent machines would completely
screw marks up you know yeah but do you
not like that world where machines have
not only intelligence but their
consciousness
and
i
you know i know that's one of your
interests one of your potential
endeavors and i'd
that the kurtz will idea that there's
some singularity we're approaching as we
just get increasing processing power
it's not processing power it's
imagination
and i think whatever the heck that means
huh whatever the heck that means yeah i
mean you you would have had imaginative
insights some of your papers on uh like
this in in in
motor in automating motoring between the
hyper-intelligent machine or the machine
human interface where the standards can
be lower for the machine and higher for
the human okay that's an insight you
would have had at some point and then
you've worked it further so i've had
insights like that as well and i have no
idea where they come from they just hit
me in the head and i write them down and
and they solve a problem that i didn't
even know my mind was working on okay
so
how can we get a machine to do that
and
i
do not know the answer but one thing i
think is the potential is i think
we think we have to create ai that has
feelings
ai that wants to survive because if you
think how our intelligence
evolved it's on this planet in a
struggle between predator and prey and
intelligence became a survival technique
i find the ideas of ernest becker with
denial of death really powerful which is
that humans
will not only have emotions and are
trying to survive
they're able to
ponder
out in the distant future their
mortality yes and that is a driving
force for even greater creation that
animals are able to do
more more uh
more primitive animals
and so there is some element where i
agree with you i think for ai systems to
have something like consciousness
they have to
fear their mortality exactly and i think
that's if you do it then you don't you
you can't produce an ai
whose behavior you can control
i mean when you have kids
yeah you can't control their behavior
you you know that's that's the trade-off
you give left to an anarchist yeah like
one of my favorite instances in my
family life is a one of my favorite my
one of my
i like all my nurses and nephews but
one's got a real quirk to her and
i was standing over her cot when she was
literally like about six months old and
she was gurgling away to herself and her
father
uh wakes his fingers said stop making
that noise and this little six-month-old
kid goes
and i said boy you're gonna have issues
with that one right yeah and and she
anarchist was born yeah and so you can't
control this life you give birth to and
that's i think the threat of ai
terrifying and exciting it is and i
think we should take that risk at some
stage
but i think to do it with what actually
let
artificial intelligence involve in this
environment in which it fears its own
death
yeah
yeah i think there's a lot of beauty
there but it's there's also a lot of a
lot of destruction that's possible so
you have to be extremely careful but
that's kind of the cutting edge of which
we all often operate as a humanity
let me ask you for advice
can you give advice to young people
in high school and college
uh maybe they're interested in economics
maybe they uh have other career ideas
what advice would you give them about a
career they can have that they could be
proud of or a life they can be proud of
mainly in a career i say don't do an
economics degree
okay i say
there's a there's a little book
on comics
econ comics taking the
out of economics
um so they should start with that
and then say screw it to an economics
degree yeah because what what you learn
is an obsolete technology learning
economics at a university is like
learning it's all make astronomy
okay earth-centric equilibrium
um
you know epicycles being added to make
your models fit the data so it's not
that economics is not a discipline worth
deeply studying it's that the university
education around that is so bad it's bad
yeah so i'd say learn system dynamics
do a course in system dynamics which you
can apply in any field
and then apply what you learn out of
system dynamics to the issues of
economics if that's what interests you
so get a sort of base engineering
education a base engineering education
uh that is far better than doing an
economics degree in terms of life
i know my life is pretty chaotic in many
many ways my friends friends and family
will tell me that every opportunity uh
but the thing is i once had this i'll
tell you an example of a really funny
incident that occurred to me because i
let this student revolt at sydney
university as i mentioned was 20 years
old
and then in my thinking about 28 or so i
went to a restaurant one night and i
found a bunch of guys all guys
who'd done accounting at the university
but also been part of the student revolt
so they hadn't seen me for about a
decade and they said to what he'd been
doing steve and i talked about what i'd
done so i've been a schoolteacher for a
while i then worked in overseas aid
i was doing computer programming at the
time and i've forgotten what else i was
doing at that point so i explained it to
all of them and they were at a bucks
night one of them having a wedding you
know coming up the next week and uh one
of them said i wish i'd done that
and there was silence around the table
that was obviously silent agreement and
i looked at them and said hang on guys
look at the downside of my life you know
like like you've all you're getting
married i don't have a girlfriend right
now um
you've all got secure jobs i'm
unemployed okay i've done it you own a
house i haven't got a car you know look
at the downside of my life and the bloke
was the kingpin of that group a very
innovative bunch of guys in the student
revolt so he said steve
we would still
all rather have done what you have done
and they did accounting because it was
safe
yeah always got a job they were bored
shitless would did you have a sense that
the chaos you're always
jumping into
was dangerous or was it just a pull pull
of it that i simply couldn't not do it
yeah it was part of me that i couldn't
swallow this economic stuff once i was
exposed to why it was so wrong then i
was on a on a crusade to make it right
and that's been part of my nature all
through my life i don't know why
so it wasn't that i made a choice to do
it is that i couldn't be true to myself
without doing it and i find a lot of
people get caught in alive where they're
doing it because it works for some
financial or other reason but they're
not being true to themselves and as as
messy as my life as much [ __ ] i've got
myself caught up in and there's a lot of
that in my personal and financial life
right now which is a pain in the ass
um
i would rather have had that nature than
not
you would rather take the pain in the
ass yep not yep yep um let me ask a dark
question
what's the darkest place you've ever
gone to in your mind so in all that
rollercoaster of life
have there been periods where it's been
really i've been i've had to cope with
depression in the last
five years
since i started reading neoclassical
economists on climate change okay sorry
to come back to that one so that's where
my wife's going to come into this story
so
i was reading richard toll
a paper from 2009 called the economics
of climate change
journal of economic perspectives i think
and i read this section where he says
that one of the ways they tried to
calibrate what climate change was due is
they assumed that the relationship
between gdp and temperature over space
would apply over time as well
yes and i read that and thought that is
so [ __ ] stupid
because all it's saying is that if
there's a 10 degree temperature
difference between new york and florida
and a 20 difference in income then a 10
degree increase in temperature will
cause gdp by 4 by 20
it is so insanely stupid so
when that read that line
i just did this
i just
you know i was in shock at how stupid it
was my wife who's thai
and brings in treats for me all day
walks into the room and says and she
speaks in a staccato english and says to
me
why are you like this and i said i'm
just doing this work on climate change
and she interrupts me says oh while you
do that stuff
nobody's interested in climate change
you can't do anything to change it if we
die we die
and that's very then perfect buddhist
grounding you know and i thought
well i can't argue with her again
yeah you know so that sort of stopped me
on the depression but that's the darkest
point when i've looked at it and i
thought that this arrogance this
stupidity this
humbug
and the economists meant that we were
potentially jeopardizing the lives of
billions of people and christ knows how
many other life forms
and the having that knowledge
is the most depressing experience of my
life
that ideas
simple models
combined with arrogance yeah can lead to
the
potential destruction of human
civilization yeah that was a very heavy
and then
your wife came in with that and broke me
out of it nature uh nature wins in the
end
yeah and that's just sort of accept the
flow of life you should you really enjoy
that book the earth of odds because it's
got that same beautiful sense to it
life will survive whatever we do i mean
they talk about the people i was
actually talking with a good mate of
mine an ex-geologist and he's now a
professor of economics and he said as a
geologist he really hated people talking
about the anthropocene epoch
and i said well it's not it shouldn't be
the anthropocene epoch it'll be the
anthropocene event
because an epoch is millions of years
and you know a huge period of life on
the planet and we might be snuffed out
in 10 000 years of human civilization
and that's not much
slower than the meteors wiping out the
dinosaurs the dinosaurs lasted for a
long time after that event so
we're we're like we'd just be a layer in
the in the in the surface of the planet
with plastics and strange metals like
that at some point so we're just neat
but life will abide life will survive us
but there's so much life we're going to
take down with us in this whole
period and there's so many of our own
lives we're going to terminate
for no good reason
i'm looking at this uh
richard tall character i'll definitely
have to look at some of his papers it
does look like
boy is the oversimplifying and do a lot
oh my god check his one on the answer on
how good it will be to lose amok
that said i'm going to
approach all of these topics with
humility
and i would like to have some
conversations that people can recommend
my default position is always with the
scientists
but even above that my default position
is with those who are humble versus
those who are arrogant yeah
this idea that because you're a
quote-unquote expert you deserve to have
arrogance is a silly idea to me again
going to the
the broader view of life on earth
nature
nature is the only one that gets to be
arrogant and it doesn't need it it
chooses not to
[Laughter]
so uh let me ask you about love
what role does love play in this whole
thing what did karl marx have uh modeled
for that oh marx was madly in love with
jenny von westhalen
uh and wrote a love poetry to her long
before he wrote dusk capital uh and he
was infatuated with her he ended up also
impregnating his um his uh housekeeper
so there's a car there's the son of karl
marx who was the son of the um
housekeeper not the journey there are
numerous daughters
so
he was a uh
he had a complicated view of love oh
yeah and uh there's a dialectic on love
there he had an idea idealistic view
with with jenny
and like he was rejected because he
wasn't uh
not by jenny she was madly in love with
him as well so it was a real passionate
love affair from the very outset
but then of course you have children
lots of them die there's a huge amount
of tragedy in his life as well
he and jenny were forced out of
chelsea by a cholera epidemic
my vision for london back in the 1850s
and 60s was was calcutta
in the in the 1970s that's really what
life was like so there's a lot of
hardship in his life as well
and he was always poor
so you know only ingalls kept him alive
financially
he applied for one job outside of
of
he never got an academic job he was
pushed out of prussia as a newspaper
author but he also
applied for a job as a clerk in the
british railway system was turned down
because they couldn't read his
handwriting
so
i think i've got a bit similar there so
um
so yeah there's a lot of love and
passion
but in general what do you think is the
role of love in the human condition it's
vital it's um i mean that that feeling
of passionate
um
desire
and respect for somebody else
and there's perverted forms of love as
well so i'll leave that out but somebody
having a really
a deep bond which goes beyond
uh just sexual attraction
like i've had that four or five times in
my life with different women at
different times and i've stuffed up the
most important one very early on um
and but that feeling is incredible
and uh
you you couldn't have life worth living
without that
so it's an essential part of who we are
but what we have to do is to transfer it
not just to the rest of our species but
to all species
and
that's i think what's what's vital and
how do we maintain that over
generations
and i think that
that that idea that we can actually hang
on to that general sense of respect and
not lose it again because the amount of
life we've terminated on this planet
uh the the war-like side of humanity
that is
too much of a defining feature of our
species that's the opposite of love it's
hate
but it's pleasure in inflicting pain on
others when you see people killing
others in a war-like environment they're
enjoying themselves okay uh it's rarely
sometimes it's self-defense but there's
when you when you've talked spoken to
people who've been involved in combat
and been involved in riots and said when
you see somebody writing bashing people
up they're enjoying themselves it's not
anger they're feeling us pleasure yeah
there's a dark aspect to human nature
very different but
there's also the capacity
to uh to rise above that and i think
like it put us on a spectrum between
chimpanzees at one extreme and bonobos
at the other yeah we're too close to the
chimpanzees you know and bananas are
just having fun having lots of sex every
time they do anything they [ __ ] first
and do the work later and then [ __ ]
afterwards to celebrate you know [ __ ]
first ask questions later
it's like that scent of a woman one of
my favorite films
where al pacino gives advice to a cat
he says when in doubt [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's good life advice for a cat
especially um we mentioned that death
seems to be maybe fundamental
to uh creating a conscious ai all right
do you think about your own death
do you um
are you afraid of it
um i'm afraid of going through it um
i'm not the other side
you're not afraid of being on the other
side i don't think there is another side
i mean i'm agnostic
and i'm atheist when pressed and
agnostic the one thing that i think i
can understand why religion exists is
the the whole thing that something
exists is itself a dilemma
okay you have to take on faith that
reality exists whether it's simulation
or actual reality it exists and that
itself can't be explained in any
scientific manner i mean you can talk
about
anti-protons and protons and the sun
being zero and so on but why did it even
happen in the first place so there's
part you simply have to take on faith
yeah
um so there was darkness before
we don't know and there's darkness after
yeah and i don't know if we're going to
be alive on the other side of that
darkness i think individually no
but the way you can live on is by what
you do to human consciousness how do you
hope people remember you um
as someone who managed to integrate um
economics
with an appreciation for life
well i have to say uh
as a bit of a callback
you're one deadly bastard
it's a huge honor that you would come
down and talk to me you're a brilliant
person you're a hilarious person the
humility shines through the brilliance
shines through thank you so much well
thank you let's spend this time you you
do the same for humanity i mean when you
when i saw that email from you my eyes
popped out on my head yeah okay well you
should hold your judgment i gotta show
you the sex dungeon i have
you you're waiting for an invitation
i'll send my wifi awesome can't wait all
right i come at
thanks for listening to this
conversation with steve keane to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from karl
marx to be radical
is to grasp things at their root
thank you for listening and hope to see
you
next time
you